monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs tout d'abord je tenais à vous
informer pour que vous ne soyez pas
étonné de la présence que vous aviez
remarqué de nos collègues de la
délégation au collectivité
territorial et en particulier de la
présidente Françoise
Gatel compte tenu de l'importance du
sujet de président Rênal dont je vous
prie d'excuser l'absence aujourd'hui à
souhaité ouvrir cette commission aux
membres du bureau de cette instance plus
particulièrement cette audition
aujourd'hui et donc je salue la présence
de nos collègues nous nous retrouvons ce
matin pour une table ronde sur le thème
des difficultés assurancielles des
collectivités territoriales en effet mes
chers collègues depuis quelques années
les collectivités doivent faire face à
des risques accrus pesant sur les
bâtiments publics et le mobilier urbain
en raison de la multiplication des
événements et des aléas
climatiques plus récemment ce constat a
été renforcé par la survenance de
mouvements sociaux les gilets jaunes les
émeutes de l'été 2023 qui ont généré des
dégâts importants sur les biens
mobiliers sur les biens immobiliers et
de nos
collectivités face à ces
épisodes de nombreux élus dénoncent les
difficultés grandissantes qu'ils
rencontrent pour assurer leur
collectivité toutes les strates étant
concerné depuis les émeutes de l'été
2023 plus de 150 communes ont ainsi reçu
un avenant et plus de 200 collectivités
ont vu leur contrat résiliés par les
deux principaux assureurs des
collectivités de sur croix les
cotisations ont parfois pu être
multipliées par tris ou quat et
certaines communes ont vu leurs
obligations d'assurance non respecté
concernant la flotte automobile ou
encore l'assurance fonctionnelle des
élus je crois que nous avons chacun dans
nos circonscriptions des exemples qui
nous viennent en tête ces difficultés
croissante résulte de plusieurs facteurs
d'un côté le le marché de l'assurance
des collectivités présente des
dysfonctionnements et s'avère peu
attirant pour les assureurs les règles
de la commande publique sont
particulièrement contraignant ce qui
conduit à ce que les assureurs ne
répondent plus ou peu aux appels d'offre
de l'autre côté la multiplication et
l'intensité des aléas climatiques et des
atteintes au bien accroissent le coût
des sinistres et fragilise le modèle
économique des contrats d'assurance
dommages au
bien les collectivités sont alors sûres
de perdre face la seule alternative qui
s'offre aux assureurs refuser de
candidater sur les marchés publics ou
augmenter leurs
tarifs face à cette situation le
gouvernement a annoncé le lancement
d'une mission pour l'assurabilité des
collectivités territoriales conduite par
Alain chrétien maire de vezou qui nous
fait le plaisir d'être là ce matin au
nom de la MF Jean y dagè ancien
président de la Fédération Nationale
Groupe
ama dans l'attente de leur conclusion le
ministre de l'Économie a étendu la
compétence du médiateur de l'assurance
aux différents entre assureurs et
collectivité sans qu'il puisse toutefois
négocier l'augmentation de cotisation ou
aider à renouveler un contrat dans ce
contexte la commission des finances du
Sénat a elle aussi décidé de créer sa
mission d'information sur les
difficultés assurancielles des
collectivités territoriales dont le
rapporteur est Jean-François Husson
rapporteur général de la commission
lui-même la mission s'est fixée comme
objectif de dresser un état des lieux de
ces difficultés et de proposer des
solutions à même de garantir des
conditions d'assurance acceptables pour
toutes les collectivités et soutenable
financièrement pour l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés pour étayer ces
travaux une consultation des élus locaux
a été lancé sur le site internet du
Sénat nous espérons que le plus grand
nombre d'élus participera afin d'établir
le constat le plus précis possible sur
les difficultés rencontrées pour lancer
cette mission nous avons décidé
d'organiser en réunion plainère cette
TBL rondes dans laquelle sont représenté
ce matin trois associations d'élus
locaux à
savoir Alain chrétien donc de vezou
représentant aujourd'hui l'association
des mères de France sa présence sera
l'occasion de faire le lien entre nos
travaux et ceux de la mission
gouvernementale Monsieur Thomas
franmentin président de l'agglomération
de foie alors j'ai peur de le dire mal
varil varil Frid varil et administrateur
d'intercommunalité de France
et monsieur Éric chal conseiller
régional d'île-de-fance qui représente
région de France nous attendons de vous
messieurs que vous puissiez nous
présenter les difficultés concrètement
rencontrées ces derniers mois appels
d'offres infructueux résiliation ou
avenant générant une hausse notable du
coût des contrats et tout autre
précision que vous pourriez être amené à
nous présenter vous pourrez aussi nous
précisez les risques auxquels vous vous
attendez à devoir faire face à l'avenir
n'hésitez pas non plus plus enfin à
esquisser les premières solutions qui
pourraient être envisagé afin
d'améliorer les relations assureur
assuré et de prévenir les risques
auxquels les collectivités sont
confrontées je vous rappelle que cette
audition cette audition fait l'objet
d'une captation vidéo et qu'elle estant
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat voilà sans plus tarder je cède la
parole à Alain chrétien pour la
MF merci Monsieur le vice-président
monsieur le rapporteur général mesdames
Messieurs les les parlementaires les
sénateurs chers collègues élus locaux je
suis Alain chrétien maire de vezou
depuis 2012 président de
l'intercommunalité de vezoule depuis
2004 j'ai été député de 2012 à 2017 et
comme l'a dit Emmanuel je suis
actuellement vice-président de la MF en
charge du développement éco du Commerce
et du Tourisme et donc depuis quelques
semaines maintenant co-président de
cette mission d'information lancé par
Bruno Lemer comme l'a rappelé manuel
Capu pour tenter de répondre à cette
situation alors un premier élément de
constat je peux prendre les deux je peux
prendre les deux voilà ça ira mieux euh
premier élément de constat même si
Emmanuel Capu a a commencer à à à
l'esquisser on a du mal de recenser
l'ensemble des collectivités qui ont
fait face à soit des résiliations soit
des augmentations brutales et
importantes de leur cotisation leur
franchis parce que toutes ne n'ont pas
l'obligation de le déclarer mais
effectivement les travaux du Sénat vont
pouvoir nous éclairer un peu plus sur
l'état de la situation actuelle mais ce
qu'on peut d'ors et déjà dire c'est que
sur les 35000 collectivités je rajoute
les syndicats les régions les interc les
départements un grand nombre continue
d'avoir leur assurance en particulier
les petites communes rurales qui sont on
peut citer les assureurs hein protégé
par group Hama dans leur quasi
exclusivité et ces petites communes
rurales ne sont pas touchées par ces
résiliations pourquoi parce que les
risques sont extrêmement limités dans
des communes de moins de 500 habitants
vous n'avez pas forcément à la fois des
piscines des crèches des écoles des
théâtres et ce et cetera donc les
risques sont plus limités en tout cas
les risques de dommage au bien excepté
les communes qui sont touchées par les
catanates mais mais j'y reviendrai tout
à l'heure donc on assiste effectivement
à un désengagement massif du monde de
l'assurance des
collectivités sur certaines catégories
de collectivité mais qui sont
extrêmement visibles puisque ce sont
elles vers lesquelles tous nos
concitoyens se tournent pour aller dans
les services publ c'est le chef-lieu de
canton c'est la la petite ville c'est la
ville moyenne c'est aussi les grandes
métropoles et une surprise que nous
avons eu aussi on a auditionné la
métropole de Lille dont on pourrait
penser que
l'ingénierie lui permett de surmonter
ces difficulté bah elle aussi la
métropole de l a été a été victime de de
ces de ces résiliations donc on peut
estimer à quelques milliers le nombre de
communes intercommunalités qui sont
touchées par ces problèmes
d'assurabilité mais euh par leur
visibilité euh ce problème a un
retentissement qui est beaucoup plus
large que ce pourcentage qui peut qui
peut paraître faible il faut dire aussi
que euh ce problème touche toutes les
communes y compris celles qui n'ont été
touchées ni par les émeutes ni par les
catastrophes climatiques j'en ve pour
preuve comme Emmanuel Capu l'a rappelé
je suis humble maire de vezou et la
ville de vezou n'a été touchée ni par
les émeutes à part euh une ou deux
poubelles brûlées ni par des
catastrophes climatique et a vu tous ces
contrats purement et simplement résiliés
dommage au bien responsabilité civile
protection fonctionnelle flotte
automobile rideau au 31 décembre en voir
madame je vous donne les clés vous êtesé
la lumière donc et et on n'est pas les
seuls mon collègue de fois pourrait
aussi en reparler donc ce qui veut dire
que ce problème d'assurabilité est
antérieur aux difficultés qu'on a connu
l'été dernier avec les émeutes et avec
les catanates puisque euh on a constaté
ce mouvement à partir de de
2021 mouvement de retrait à partir de
2021 avant les émeutes naturellement les
émeutes et les catanates ont été des
catalyseurs des accélérateurs de ce
mouvement mais ce mouvement avait
commencé bien avant ce qui veut dire
qu'on a un problème structurel sur le
marché de l'assurance pour les
collectivités un problème d'attractivité
en gros c'est-à-dire que les assureurs
se disent les collectivités c'est trop
compliqué ça coûte trop cher donc on va
pas s'emmerder avec ça continuons
d'assurer les entreprises les
particuliers parce que ça au moins on
sait faire i sign en bas du de la page
et et tout va bien les collectivités
c'est quand même beaucoup plus compliqué
puis en plus ou là là vu ce qui se passe
en ce moment avec le réchauffement
climatique il faut s'attendre encore à
des choses encore plus graves donc
sortons vite de ce de cet environnement
parce que c'est ça peut poser problème
on relativise aussi puisque les deux
principaux assureurs lasmac les Groupama
sont des mutuels et donc elles ne sont
pas là pour gagner de l'argent elles
sont par définition là des des mutuels
pour équilibrer et mais au moins pour
éviter de perdre l'argent parce que le
le chiffre d'affaires global hein y
compris l'assurance vie de l'assurance
est à peu près de 230 milliards
d'euros le chiffre d'affaires pour les
collectivités c'est 200 millions d'euros
donc vous voyez c'est c'est tout petit
par rapport à la grande masse
naturellement si on inclut l'assurance
vie ça ça ça dévoie un peu le problème
mais si on enlève l'assurance vie on est
à 1 5 2 % du chiffre d'affair des
assureurs donc non seulement ils se
disent ça risque de me coûter de
l'argent et puis on plus ça n'est que 1
% de mon chiffre d'affaires donc
qu'est-ce que je vais m'ennuyer avec ces
gens-là donc je je ne m'y intéresse plus
donc on est dans un système où nous
dépendons totalement de nos assureurs et
les assureurs eux pas d'obligation mis à
part quelques contrats mais je vais
revenir de de nous assurer donc on
assiste vraiment à un problème de de
dialogue de compréhension entre le monde
de l'assurance et le monde des
collectivités et ce problème
d'assurabilité il est pas nouveau il est
cyclique on l'a déjà connu j'en parlais
avec le rapporteur général il y a
quelques instants on l'a connu il y a
une trentaine d'années on a connu il y a
une dizaine d'années et donc
régulièrement on a au vu du contexte des
tensions entre le monde de l'assurance
et le monde des collectivité pendant de
nombreuses années et autour de cette
table beaucoup sans doute ont été élus
locaux ont signait le contrat tous les
ans en fermant les yeux on orgalisait
même pas les clauses on avait l'habitude
on était on connaissait bien notre
assureur ça ne posait aucun problème
peut-être aussi parce que pendant une
dizaine d'années des années 2010 à 2020
les cotisations ont baissé peut-être de
manière artificielle et là aussi FAA
peut-être y revenir parce que le tarif
technique est quand même le tarif qui
permet à tout le monde à la fois d'être
protégé et puis de pas perdre de
l'argent certains se sont éloignés du
tarif technique à la baisse créant de
lui-même un déséquilibre dont on paye
aujourd'hui les conséquences donc il
faudra aussi peut-être demander au
régulateurs comme il y a le régulateur
de l'énergie il y a aussi vous le savez
l'ut autorité prudentielle d'avoir un
œil un peu plus averti sur les tarifs
qui sont proposés aux uns aux uns et aux
autres donc pour faire cours et et pour
avancer dans la réflexion un constat
général de désengagement qui concerne
les communes les plus dotés en service
public qui concerne surtout les Daab
dommage au bien mais qui par conséquence
effet dominau intègrre aussi les autres
types de contrats en sachant que les
seuls contrats qui sont obligatoires
c'est la flotte automobile et c'est
l'assurance fonctionnelle le reste vous
n'êtes pas obligé de vous assurer pour
protéger votre école votre théâtre vos
piscines vous pouvez faire de
l'auto-assurance et là-dessus je pense
qu'il ne serait pas il n'est pas
nécessaire de revenir dessus parce que
qui dit obligation dit contrainte et qui
dit contrainte dit augmentation des
tarifs et autres donc l'obligation de
flotte automobile c'est logique vous
pouvez pas laisser vos cantonniers vos
employés municipaux rouler dans des
voitures qui sont pas assuré notamment
pour les tiers et puis l'assurance
protection fonctionnelle effectivement
là aussi c'est obligatoire pour payer
les congés maladies les absences et
cetera pour le reste ça n'est pas
obligatoire on nous dit aussi c'est une
fausse bonne idée pourquoi ne pas créer
un assureur des collectivités comme vous
avez la banque des territoires nous
pourrions avoir l'assureur des
territoires fausse bonne idée puisque
cet assureur des territoires il existe
déjà c'est la smacle qui a justement été
créé par les collectivités pour assurer
les collectivités sauf que plus vous
concentrez un risque sur une seule
personne plus ce risque est fragile et
la personne qui va avec aussi une bonne
assurance c'est une assurance qui
partage le risque dans le temps et dans
l'espace il vaut mieux que beaucoup
d'assureurs prennent un petit bout de
chaque risque plutôt que de faire
concentrer le risque sur un ou deux ce
qui est le cas actuellement et donc les
difficultés qu'on a aujourd'hui donc
l'enjeu monsieur le vice-président
monsieur le rapporteur général de nos
missions respectives c'est de donner à
nouveau envie aux assureurs de nous
assurer il faut donner envie et pour
donner envie c'est comme mon amour il
faut montrer des preuves de confiance il
faut que les assureur nous fasse
confiance et c'est le deuxème point de
mon propos et j'en aurai trois avant que
nous passions au témoignage de mes deux
collègues le premier gage de confiance
c'est d'intégrer la culture du risque
dans le fonctionnement de nos
collectivités quand vous parlez un chef
d'entreprise d'une PME de 50 100
salariés il a un risque manager qui est
chargé de vérifier que l'ensemble des
mesures ont été prises pour éviter les
incendies pour éviter euh des
catastrophes qui amèneraient à la à
l'arrêt de la production et en plus
ensuite à l'assureur au paiement des
pines d'exploitation parce que non
seulement dans une entreprise euh quand
vous avez un bâtiment qui brûle ben il
faut le remplacer le reconstruire et
ensuite il faut rembourser les peines
d'exploitation ce qui est pas le cas
dans les collectivités mais en tout cas
dans les PME dans le monde de
l'entreprise la culture du risque est
quelque chose d'extrêmement précieux qui
permet euh à l'assureur de se dire
l'entreprise a pensé à tout ou à presque
tout donc j'ai confiance en elle pour
éviter les dommages collatéraux ou les
ou les surcouts donc il faut qu'on
trouve des solutions pour intégrer la
culture du risque dans nos collectivités
et pour ce faire il faut qu'on ait déjà
une bonne
connaissance de notre patrimoine et je
mets au défi chaque élu local chaque
président d'Interco chaque maire de
connaître le le le le moindre mètre
carré dont la collectivité est
propriétaire non seulement de connaître
le M nombre de mèes carrés mais le taux
de véuseté l'état de ses bâtiments et
cetera et cetera il y a une vraie
difficulté dans nos collectivités mais
aussi à l'état on a auditionné les
services centraux du ministère des
Finances une vraie difficulté à
connaître l'état du patrimoine de nos
collectivités et donc pour bien définir
la nature de la protection il faut bien
définir la nature des besoins et donc
bien connaître l'état de notre
patrimoine et là c'est une vraie
difficulté naturellement vous vous avez
le cadastre hein c'est facile on va sur
le cadastre quand il est numérisé c'est
encore plus simple on tape comme une de
fois et il y a la liste de tous les
biens qui s'affichent mais une fois
qu'on a fait ça il faut ensuite
inspecter chacun des biens avec des
étages sans étages des ascenseurs pas
d'ascenseur des réflectionion pas de
réflexion il y a un vrai sujet dans la
connaissance du patrimoine c'est le
point de départ pour réaliser ce que
nous aujourd'hui on on
on on dénomme une expertise préalable
qui serait un document un diagnostic
complet qui soit la base de la rédaction
d'un cahier des charges le plus précis
possible pour l'assureur donc il faut
faire confiance il faut que l'assureur
nous fasse confiance et pour ça il faut
qu'on connaisse bien nos besoins pour
qu'ensuite l'assureur puisse bien y
répondre et c'est le troisème point de
mon propos pour pas être trop
long il faut qu'on ait une réflexion sur
le Code des Marchés publ je ne dis pas
qu'il faut le modifier je ne dis pas
qu'il faut le le le réformer par voie
réglementaire ou par voie législative
c'est c'est prématuré en tout cas il y a
un travail de pédagogie à faire sur
l'utilisation des différents outils qui
sont à notre disposition dans le code
des marchés publics appel d'offre
procédure négocié marché de gré àagé
dialogue compétitif or beaucoup d'entre
nous par principe par instinct par
habitude utilisons la procédure de
l'appel
d'offre avec toutes les
rigidités subséquentes c'està-dire qu'un
appel d'offre vous rédigez votre besoin
j'ai besoin d'une voiture de 5 places
bleue avec les avec deux rétroviseurs
voilà et ensuite ben tous les
concessionnaires viennent vous voir sauf
que si un concessionnaire vous dit bah
moi j'ai une voiture bleue avec avec
quatre roues de rétroviseur mais en plus
j'ai une antenne sur le toit pour capter
la radio ah mais j'avais pas demandé
l'antenne et ben donc le contrat est
refusé l'appel d'offre est trin
infuctueux parce que la réponse ne
correspond pas à ce que l'appel d'offre
avait défini Paron de cette métaphore un
peu triviale mais c'est pour faire
simple l'appel d'offre ne nous permet
pas de bien définir le besoin et ne
permet donc pas à l'assureur de bien y
répondre et sa réponse étant toujours
souvent différente de ce qu'on lui
demande et bien l'appel d'offre est
déclaré infructueux alors je vais aller
plus loin dans l'hypocrisie parfois on
le fait siamment puisque le code des
marchés publics nous permet à l'issue
d'une procédure infructueuse de passer
par la procédure négociée donc on a déjà
là espèce de cynisme ou
d'hypocrisie soit on le fait sans le
savoir et par B on découvre une clause
du du code des marchés publics qui nous
permet de passer en marché négocié mais
on a perdu 6 mois voir un an on a
dégradé nos relations avec les assureurs
on a compliqué le le système pour tout
le monde pour arriver enfin à négocier
donc ce qu'on a aussi dans nos
différentes enquêtes découvertes c'est
que l'appel d'offre n'est pas la seule
procédure qu'on peut utiliser on a aussi
la capacité de prendre la procédure de
marché négocié qui répond à des critères
extrêmement précis et il faudra qu'on
obtienne de l'État l'assurance que quand
collectivité passe par la procédure de
marché négocié elle se fasse pas retoqué
par l'État parce que l'utilisation de
cette procédure répond à des critères
extrêmement précis sauf qu'aujourd'hui
la complexité qui atteint des critères
est telle pour les marchés d'assurance
qu'on peut s'appuyer sur ce critère- là
pour utiliser la procédure de marché
négocié mais je le rappelle c'est une
procédure qui permet de négocier donc de
faire des allers-retours entre les
prestataires et et et les demandeurs
elle est lourde elle nécessite des
procédures de publicité elle nécessite
des allés-retours en terme calendaire
extrêmement précis ça n'est pas en
claquant des doigts en demandant à son
assureur de venir dans le bureau du
maire et puis de signer au bois de la
page c'est quand même une procédure
extrêmement complexe qui nécessite et
c'est la fin de mon propos une
ingénierie extrêmement importante qu'on
peut se payer quand on est une grosse
collectivité mais aujourd'hui je parle
aussi sous le contrôle de mes collègues
toutes les collectivités moyennes on va
dire au-dessus de de 10000 habitants
prennent un amo pour les aider à rédiger
leur CA des charges mais ça n'est pas
encore suffisant parce que laamo il fait
avec ce qu'on lui donne s'il y a pas une
expertise préalable s'il y a pas une
bonne connaissance du patrimoine s'il y
a pas une bonne connaissance du besoin
et ben le le l'AMO essaie de vous aider
à trouver un assureur mais avec des
éléments très fragmentaires très
partiels qui ne permettent pas de
sécuriser le contrat qui sera signé donc
voilà Monsieur le vice-président
monsieur le rapporteur général en
quelques mots quelques pistes qui sont
qui sont tracées mais qu'on pourra
naturellement
approfondir ce matin en sachant que
comme vous euh enfin nous en tout cas on
nous l'a demandé on on donnera nos
préconisations fin mars début avril qui
ne seront que des préconisations parce
que ça sert à rien de travailler si le
gouvernement nous dit non non ça je veux
pas en entendre parler c'est donc on
aura quelques préconisations de principe
et si le gouvernement est d'accord on
les creusera dans les mois qui suivront
ce problème est un problème récurrent
qui ne peut pas être réglé en l'espace
de 3 semaines et et et la jurisprudence
grand port de Marseille n'est qu'un
pisalé qui ne résout rien qui ne résout
absolument rien donc il faudra que nous
puissions reconstruire construire ou
reconstruire une relation saine entre
les assureurs et les collectivités et
donc ça passera par ces mois de
discussion avec eux parce que on ne fera
rien sans eux on ne fera rien sous la
contrainte on ne fera rien sous
l'obligation mais pour terminer notre
objectif est de rassurer les
assureurs tout un
programme merci beaucoup Alain chrétien
pour votre
intervention je
propose de passer la parole à Monsieur
Frantin pour intercommunalité de
France et Monsieur le vice-président
monsieur le rapporteur général madames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
chers collègues également évidemment de
la MF et de région de France ben tout
d'abord le premier point c'est de saluer
hein cette mission l'information du
Sénat parce qu'effectivement cette
problématique des assurances est forte
au sein de des collectivités au sens
général du terme moi je vais m'exprimer
certes comme
vice-présidentintercommunauté de France
mais aussi comme un modeste élu local je
vais vous expliquer à quel point un
modeste élu local
euh donc moi je suis président d'une
communauté d'agglomération 30000
habitants très rural en Arriège avec
certes une ingénierie mais enfin qui
reste limitée vous imaginez bien dans
dans notre belle Arriège certes mais
Arriège rural et avec nos moyens
modestes et puis euh un matin de mai
2023 le Directeur Général des Services
m'apporte un courrier qui faisait à peu
près moins de 10 lignes de notre
rassureur disant à compter du 31
décembre 2023 nous résilions
unilatéralement votre assurance dommage
au bien signé
point rien de plus alors moi voilà j'ai
fait un peu de droit résiliation
unilatérale non mais c'est c'est nous ça
c'est sans les collectivités ça c'est
pas possible ça ben non ben non les
assureurs ont la capacité de
résilier
unilatéralement et donc et en plus en
vous expliquant ce qui s'est passé par
ailleurs c'est que lorsqu'on a passé le
marché entre pour l'année 2021 entre 21
et 2022 nous avons donc effectivement
passer un marché nous avons eu une seule
offre d'un assureur allemand en
augmentation 98
% il nous fallait bien une assurance
nous l'avons
affermi et puis en 2023 ce même assureur
pour l'année 2023 nous dit si vous
n'acceptez pas une augmentation de 35 %
et bien je résilierai on accepte cette
augmentation ça l'a pas empêché de
résilier donc me voilà mis dans le je
dirais dans le bain des des
problématiques d'assurance et
entre-temps parce que pour rejoindre
Alain chrétienin dis les choses telles
qu'elles sont on a relancé un marché euh
nous avions eu euh une offre qui ne
correspondait pas du tout à notre
demande et donc oui on a trouvé par le
gré àré voilà je v pas dire autrement
donc au final nous sommes assurés tant
mieux mais ça a été euh par la mécanique
du du du
gréagré et à l'époque je me suis dit que
j'étais un peu seul sur ce sujet et puis
ben manifestement euh voilà autour de
moi c'était euh beaucoup plus important
que cela et nous étions de nombreuses
intercommunalités ou communes ou
syndicat de déchets j'y insiste aussi
parce qu'on a des nombreuses remontées
de syndicat de déchets avec des grandes
difficultés à assurer leurs
incinérateurs ou leur ou ou ou ou leurs
exploitations vis-à-vis des risques euh
qui euh donc voilà avec ces grandes
difficultés donc effectivement envoler
des cotisations résiliation unilatérale
appel d'offre
infructueux alors je vais pas revenir
sur ce que sur tout ce qu'a défendu
Alain chrétien parce que très
franchement d'in de France évidemment on
rejoint les toutes les propositions qui
ont été faites par Alain chrétien
peut-être appuyer sur quelques sur
quelques éléments si si si si vous
voulez
bien déjà juste je pense que tout le
monde effectivement on a bien du mal à
identifier vraiment le nombre exact de
collectivités
mais pas plus tard que mercredi dernier
il y avait la journée finance d'interc
de France et les vœux là et donc il y
avait on avait fait une table ronde sur
la question des assurances parce que
vraiment ça inquiète tout le monde moi
il y a pas un moment où il y a pas
d'inquiétude et donc on a dit bah levez
la main ceux qui ont une problématique
d'assurance et il y avait 2 tiers de la
salle qui ont levé la main quoi donc je
voilà il y il y a aussi certes il y a
peut-être pas d'objectivation précise
mais on voit bien les grandes
difficultés et je redis ici moi je suis
pas un spécialiste des assurances je
suis un modeste élu local qui essaie de
trouver des solutions pour lui-même et
pour et pour ses
collègues donc sur le premier point
effectivement je reprends presque par la
fin de ce que disait Alain chrétien
c'est la jurisprudence Grand Port
Maritime de de Marseille qui nous semble
également
insatisfaisante la question que que l'on
se pose
c'est la clause exorbitante du droit
commun qui permet effectivement à un
assureur de se
retirer autant il nous semble évidemment
ça demande plus d'expertise autant il
nous semble peut-être compréhensible
qu'un assureur puisse se retirer
lorsqu'il y a une forte augmentation de
sinistralité dans des cas très précis
autant lorsqu'il n'y a pas
d'augmentation de sinistralité et
lorsque les conditions du contrat sont
restées comme
telles je je m'interroge voilà comme
encore une fois comme modeste local sur
cette capacité de retrait unilatérale de
de de notre côté nous n'avions pas
d'augmentation de sinistralitaire Thomas
peut-être rappeler ce que signifie la
jurisprudence grand port maritime de
Marseille pour les collègues oui donc en
fait cette jurisprudence c'est le fait
qu'une collectivité est gagnée par
rapport à la résiliation unilatérale
d'un assureur mais la jurisprudence dit
simplement l'assureur doit maintenir ses
conditions pendant un temps dit
raisonnable dont on considère que ça
doit être à peu près un an voilà enfin
en tous les cas au regard de ce qu'on
peut lire de de de de la jurisprudence
donc ça vient atténuer cette capacité de
résiliation unilatérale mais enfin ça ne
la ça ne la remet pas en cause ça c'est
le le le premier point le deuxième point
on s'est interrogé sur la capacité
peut-être eu égard à la difficulté de de
on rejoint aussi sur l'idée de
l'auto-assurance au regard de la forte
sinistralité notamment liée au
dérèglement climatique enfin je vois pas
comment un système d'autoassurance
mutualisé va pouvoir va pouvoir tenir ça
nous semble on sait que Laas SMAC a dû
être recapitalisé par la Maïf ça nous
semble extrêmement difficile par contre
n'y a-t-il pas une réflexion sur l'idée
d'une forme de panier moyen pardon de de
panier minimum qui consisterait à dire
il faut que les collectivités parce
qu'elles assurent des missions de
services public on revient quand même
là-dessus hein nous assurons des
missions de Service publics il faudra
que les assureurs puissent permettre un
une sorte de panier moyen minimum pardon
d'assurance pour
ces pour ces
collectivités
sur sur le code des marchés publics je
je je rejoins Alain chrétien
avec le fait que ce qui nous remonte du
terrain c'est le fait d'avoir des
assurances sur effectivement la capacité
de recourir à des formes de marché
public qui soi plus souple parce qu'on a
beaucoup de remonté en disant oui mais
ça nous semble pas clair sur le fait
qu'on puisse vraiment rentrer dans des
procédures plus négociées on a parfois
des servic des préfectures des contrôles
de légalité en préfecture qui peuvent
être très rigoureux de ce point de vue
et donc il faudrait effectivement qu'il
a une forme de doctrine d'État parce que
la capacité à dialoguer avec l'assureur
nous semble également une bonne une
bonne piste et de la même manière
franchement il y a une forme
d'hypocrisie parce que parfois il y a on
organise l'incapacité des assureurs à
répondre au marché public pour pouvoir
après passer en gré à gré ça n sembleit
pas quand même une bonne manière de
faire en tous les cas au moins du point
de vue du point de vue de de de la
sécurité
juridique sur la sur la connaissance des
risques la culture des risques je
rejoins complètement ce que disait Alain
chrétien peut-être en appuyant sur un
autre élément c'est la question de la
gestion du risque B c'est vrai qu'il
faut se il faut reconnaître dans nos
collectivités les assurances pendant
longtemps c'était bon ben on renouvelle
et puis voilà quoi ma fois on renouvelle
l'assurance qu'on avait avant et donc ne
s'est pas
développé une culture effectivement
également de gestion du risque de savoir
ce qu'on déclare ce qu'on déclare pas
par rapport à ses niveaux de
sinistralité comment voilà comment on
arrive aussi à rester dans les clous de
de de de cette de cette
assurance donc une meilleure
identification des risques une culture
du risque nous disons juste aussi et je
pense qu'on le dira collectivement
attention aux usine à gaz parce que nos
communes notamment les plus petites
d'entre elles sont déjà voilà écrasé par
un certain nombre l'importance des
normes des questionnaires à remplir et
cetera et cetera il faut voir vraiment
la manière dont on peut faire ça parce
qu'il faut que ce soit accessibles pour
l'ensemble de de nos collègues et par
contre bon pour le coup évidemment les
intercommunaités peuvent jouer leur rôle
de mutualisation en aidant un à la
connaissance de risque et puis deux
effectivement à pouvoir répondre à à à
ces éventuels questionnaires peut-être
faut-il on en a pas parlé mais peut-être
faut-il ajouter la question du risque
cyber qui devient aussi un risque très
important euh alors voilà je donc je le
pointe juste je sais pas quel est le le
le périmètre exact de de de la mission
je pense que ça mérite une mission
spécifique voilà mais voilà nous
voilà parce que nous on sent monter
aussi du territoire vraiment cette
question des risques cyber de plus en
plus de de plus en plus forte et puis
ensuite je rejoins ce que disait Alain
chrétien sur le régime de catastrophe
naturelle avec peut-être une meilleure
une clarification on va dire de ce de ce
régime voilà je remercie de de de votre
écoute sur ce
sujet merci beaucoup monsieur Fromentin
je donne donc la parole à Eric chal qui
va nous présenter les constats la
position de région de France Merci
monsieur le le président euh tout
d'abord merci pour votre invitation je
suis très honoré de venir dans cette
maison que que je connais bien j'ai ici
des visages familiers et pour tout dire
aussi beaucoup d'amis donc je suis
vraiment très honoré d'être dans cette
prestigieuse commission des finances ce
matin vous dire également que on s'est
pas parlé avec Alain chrétien avant ce
matin enfin on se parle souvent mais on
n a pas parlé de ce sujet ensemble et
vous allez voir que avec des chemins un
peu différents on arrive on balise on
arrive à peu près systématiquement au
même mêmes étapes tous les chemins
mentavezou effectivement et euh et et et
et on on a beaucoup de beaucoup de de de
rapprochement je pas vous faire un un
bilan fastidieux de de la situation de
l'assurabilité de de la strate régionale
région de France vous a préparé un un un
dossier on le tient à votre disposition
je vais vous donner quelques exemples
sur en tout cas sur quelques régions
parce que on pourrait imaginer que par
rapport au potentiel financier des
régions par rapport à leur force de
frappe par rapport à la masse de mètres
carrés de de bâtiments à assurer le
nombre de personnels on pourrait
finalement avoir une espèce de de taille
critique qui nous permettrait deavir une
muttilisation interne du risque et de
pas avoir de difficulté je prends le cas
de la région Île-de-France he don dont
je suis élu on a le la plus grande
région d'Europe on a un budget de de 5
milliards d'euros on a 6,5 millions de
mètres Carr à à assurer plus de 500
bâtiments on pourrait imaginer qu'on a
pas de difficulté pourtant même nous on
n'est pas en infructuusité hein mais on
a un problème de d'offre où on se limite
en fait en réalité à une seule offre et
donc ça ça va limiter je vais y venir le
notre capacité à faire jouer la
concurrence et pourtant comme nous
sommes une très grosse collectivité on a
ce levier de la réassurance et on peut
aussi finalement tout envoyer balader he
pardon pour l'expression dire à un
moment donné si c'est plus raisonnable
on s sur nous-même mais toutes les
collectivités n'ont pas cette
possibilité d'avoir ce levier de dire on
se débrouille par nous-même voilà je
vais donner juste quelques exemples
assez parlants sans donner le nom des
régions euh mais une région du centre de
la France on a une prime contrat dommage
au bien qui a augmenté de 70 % il y a 2
ans cette année la région a refuser une
nouvelle augmentation de 25 % et ça a
conduit à une résiliation du contrat une
région du Sud-Ouest ça vous laisse la
possibilité on en a deux hein voilà
l'assureur a adressé un préavis de
résiliation du marché au 31 décembre ça
a conduit la collectivité à accepter
tenez-vous bien de multiplié par 1000
euh la franchise qui passe donc
maintenant à 1000000ons d'EUR ça fausse
évidemment
totalement la capacité voilà dans une
région de l'Ouest ça nous en donne
beaucoup plus là malgré deux
consultations la collectivité n'a pas eu
d'offre pour son assurance de deuxème
ligne pour assurer son siège or c'est un
monument historique et vous comprenez
aussi ce que ça ce que ça peut induire
et je m'étendneri pas sur la situation
des haut Fran qui est en pleine
renégociation et je pas là pour
compliquer le le chemin qui est le leur
alors Alain chrétien nous a parlé tout à
àure de de l'ensemble des des causes
conjoncturelles et il a parfaitement
raison de souligner que en fait c'est
antérieur aux événements climatique
dramatique qui ont augmenté sur sur sur
le pays dans les dernières deux trois
dernières années et évidemment aux
émeutes de cet été et parfaitement
raison de nous de nous dire que ça
remonte à 2020 2021 même un petit peu
avant mais en tout cas il y a une
amplification à ce moment-là et c'est
important aussi de le comprendre parce
que en fait c'est la conséquence de la
crise covid et du ralentissement de
l'économie mondiale parce que les
assurances font des placements sur les
sur les marchés boursiers et à partir du
moment où l'économie mondial ralentit et
ben les placements les marchés boursiers
sont moins fructueux et là où les
entreprises les sociétés d'assurance
pouvaient refaire en fait leur marges
faire des marges sur les marchés
boursiers des pertes techniques qu'ell
subissaient sur tous les marchés que ce
soit de l'assurance privée encore une
fois comme comme chrétien l'a dit les
collectivités territoriales ne sont
qu'un petit volet hein de de de de de de
cette masse qui les concerne et bien
évidemment c'est une incidence sur elle
et donc elle perd aussi cette capacité à
avoir des marge et l'autre chose qui est
liée à ça dans les causes
conjoncturelles c'est que les facteurs
climatiques jouent à l'échelle mondiale
hein pas de la France jouent sur le
marché de la réassurance et et le c'est
donc les assurances sont obligés de se
réassurer les primes leurs propres
primes augmentent considérablement et ça
va aller croissant puisque on sait
qu'avec l'évolution climatique à
l'horizon de 2050 les risques de
sinistre rien qu'en France he tous les
calculs nous emmènent à une progression
d'à peu près 100 % en général on dit 93
% d'aggravation des risques climatiques
à l'horizon 2050 donc forcément ça avir
une incidence pérenne et j'ose même plus
parler de cause conjoncturell parce que
ça devient une cause structurelle voilà
ça c'est pour cette situation dont sur
laquelle je ne veux pas m'étendre mais
Alain chrétien a esquissé également un
point qui me semble très important qui
n'est plus une cause conjoncturelle et
je voudrais insister là-dessus parce que
je crois qu'on passerait à côté d'une
partie du sujet si on pointait pas du
doigt cette difficulté là il y a une
cause structurelle qui est celle de la
situation on l'a dit de quasi monopole
d'une ou deux sociétés d'assurance
mutuelle sur sur le marché monopo sub
j'y viens justement et je c'est pour ça
que je veux sans apporter de réponse sur
ce je là je pense que c'est important de
de formaliser les choses c'est la poule
et l'F est-ce que c'est parce
que finalement toutes les sociétés
d'assurance se sont désintéressé du
marché des collectivités territoriales
on se retrouve avec une ou deux sociétés
sur le marché ou est-ce parce que ces
sociétés ont pratiqué à un moment donné
une politique ultra compétitive
j'oseraai pas dire agressive mais en
tout cas ultra compétitive sur le prix
du marché qui a fait que toutes les
sociétés les autres ont renoncé en
disant on peut pas suivre à ces
conditions là on n plus en situation de
suivre en plus les appels d'offres je
vais revenir c'est très compliqué à
monter faut des cellules entières ça
prend beaucoup de temps pour les pour
ces sociétés elle lâche elle lâche et
comme si elles savent qu'à la fin de
toute manière elle n'auront pas les
contrats elles se sont désengagées on a
vu progressivement des stratégies
économiques des assureurs les uns après
les autres de dire on s'intéresse plus
collectivité locale et c'est pas
simplement parce qu'il y a pas d'argent
à se faire pardon d'être un peu
prosaïque mais c'est parce que en fait
on sait qu'on les gagnera pas donc on
peut pas s'aligner on perd pas de temps
on y va plus donc vous avez une ou deux
sociétés qui gardent le marché pour nous
ça a été très intéressant pendant
longtemps pendant des années on a pu
bénéficier en
réalité de tarif d'un coût de
l'assurance en réalité inférieur au prix
du mar donc quand ça explose on est
agacé à juste titre mais pendant très
longtemps on a eu des assurances en
dessous des prix du marché et quand ces
entreprises ces sociétés se retrouvent
dans la situation dans laquelle elles
sont aujourd'hui c'està-dire une
sinistralité qui augmente partout
simultanément elles ne sont plus en
situation de pouvoir
payer donc elles n'ont plus qu'une seule
solution c'est d'augmenter très
significativement les primes de monter
les franchises également c'est l'exemple
que j'ai tout à l'heure où la franchise
était multipliée par 1000 où finalement
on n plus assuré en réalité
l'augmentation de la prime n'est pas
très élevée mais comme la franchise est
telle que on s'en sort pas et nous
collectivité on ne peut plus se
retourner vers d'autres acteurs parce
que tout le monde s'est désengagés ils
ont même plus les équipes pour pouvoir à
un moment donné s'intéresser à nous il y
a plus personne qui s'occupe des
collectivités territoriales à part ces
deux sociétés donc je formulé ce
point-là parce que comme l' dit avec un
un trait d'humour en disant rassurons
les assureurs en tout cas
intéressons-les il va falloir créer les
conditions parce que si on ve avoir le
juste prix le la juste valeur de
l'assurance la valeur de l'assurance il
va falloir à un moment donné qu'on
trouve le prix et le prix
malheureusement c'est pas celui qu'on a
payé pendant des années évidemment c'est
pas celui qu'on va vouloir nous imposer
maintenant parce que ces entreprises en
grande difficultés et en situation de
quasi monopole peuvent maintenant nous
imposer des primes qui nous conviennent
pas donc je vais balayer assez
rapidement parce que tout a été très
très très très bien précisé les les
différentes pistes et notre propre
sentiment à région de France sur les
pistes qui ont été qui ont été avancées
euh d'abord la simplification des
procédures d'appel d'offre alors je je
sais que le monde entier nous envie en
France notre code des marchés publics
essaie de le le copier sans jamais
réussir à parfaitement lesgaler tant
mieux pour eux mais c'est effectivement
un sujet alors je vais pas m'engouffrer
dans cette brèche là parce que ce serait
un sujet bien trop vaste néanmoins ça
sert à quoi ces procédures d'appel
d'offre ça sert à deux choses ça sert à
à garantir une concurrence équitable une
concurrence ne faussée et ça sert
évidemment et c'est légitime à prévenir
contre la corruption VO les conflits
d'intérêts voilà mais quand on se
retrouve dans des situation ou en fin de
course on a au mieux une offre et
parfois zéro offre de quelle concurrence
ne fossé se prétoocheton et quand ça va
finir de toute manière à la fin par une
procédure de créagré de quel conflit
d'intérêt se protège-t-on donc il va
quand même falloir à un moment donné
qu'on se pose la question de la
simplification de ces procédures mais on
touche à des choses qui sont tellement
sensibles dans notre pays que c'est pas
moi qui vous proposz les pistes de
simplification mais vous avez le droit
d'y réfléchir le deuxième sujet on se
rejoint également c'est la question de
de cette assurance publique hein cette
assurance des collectivités locales
c'est pas illégitime en soi on se dit
les collectivités territoriales
remplissent une mission de service
public cette mission de service public
ne peut pas ne pas être assurée donc à
ce titre il est logique que les
collectivités territoriales aent une
garantie d'assurabilité et donc on en
vient à cette proposition qui est celle
de de l'assurance de la démocratie
locale un peu comme François beou avait
proposé la banque de la démocratie
locale partant du principe que partant
du principe que les que les monsieur le
Président Monsieur rapporteur passant du
principe que le que les que que les
banques ne prétendent plus et qu'on a
besoin des partis politiques pour faire
vivre la démocratie on a besoin d'une
banque de la démocratie je je crois pas
non plus à ce système là pour pour pour
deux raisons la première c'est que je ne
pense pas qu' qu'il y ait de risques
inassura de de quoi parle-t-on on parle
de de flotte automobile on parle de
choses qui ne sont en réalité pas si
compliqué que ça quand on trouve les
moyens d'assurer des centrales
nucléaires des sites des vaiseaux des
des des des industries pétrochimiques
sur tout le territoire il n'est pas
impossible de trouver un moyen d'assurer
nos flottes automobiles et les quelques
autres sujets des collectivités locales
donc je ne crois pas que les
collectivité soit inassurable et à
partir de là l'idée que la solution
viendrait d'une l'assurance de la
démocratie locale je crois que ça
continuerait à fausser le marché et et
en plus en fin de compte fréquemment on
l'adosserait à la CDC enfin je sais pas
quel serait le système et elle arrivit
ce serait de toute manière enfin il y a
un ancien président de la République qui
disait que c'est gratuit c'est l'État
qui paye je je crois que c'est jamais
gratuit et que que ce soit les
collectivités locales ou l'état en fin
de compte c'est quand même le
contribuable qui paye donc je ne crois
pas à ce système et comme je vous le
disais juste avant la solution c'est
d'aller vers une vraie concurrence et
donc de réintéresser je je crois la
pluralité d'offre privée plutôt que une
offre publique
unique le le recours aux amo a peut-être
une petite nuance alors une mini
digression sur sur les amo je pense
que le pardon c'est pas le rôle de la MO
lui-même qui est très important qui a un
support technique essentiel pour les
collectivités locales les plus petites
collectivités non pas les moyens
techniques donc c'est la question de
savoir comment on pourrait les
accompagner et les aider d'avoir des
structures qui fasse qu'une petite
collectivité puisse être aidée par un
amo en Souha est une bonne chose mais
j'attire votre attention sur sur le fait
que ça fausse le rapport le rapport
entre l'assuré et l'assureur partout
ailleurs à part dans notre marché de
d'appel d'offre c'est l'intermédiaire
donc le courtier l'agent qualifions-le
comme on veut qui fait ce rôle
d'intermédiaire et ce courtier en fait
il est au service du client et le client
dans notre cas c'est la collectivité
avec notre système on a un marché un peu
faussé où la
devient l'agent de la collectivité
locale il défend la collectivité locale
et en face le courtier l'intermédiaire
devient plus en plus celui qui va être
le coordonnateur de d'assureurs il va
essayer d'intéresser des assurances au
risque il va les organiser et en fait il
devient le client des assureurs alors
que partout ailleurs dans les
entreprises c'est pas le cas le courtier
est au service du client et nous
aujourd'hui on est dans ce système où
laemo est au service de la collectivité
et le courtier au service des assureurs
et ça faut cette relation parce que
normalement le courtier il est là pour
pour son client et aujourd'hui le client
donc il faut intéresser aussi le
courtier à ce qu'il devienne comment
dire le le bras armé de la collectivité
et pas l'inverse et ça c'est assez
important je pense que si on ne recrée
pas cette relation là on aura du mal
sauf que dans nos codes de marché public
qu'est-ce qu'on fait enfin dans nos
marchés on passe des procédures d'appel
d'offre pour choisir l'assureur nous on
passe pas de procédure pour choisir le
courtier dans les entreprises en général
l'appel d'offre il se fait sur un
courtier et après une fois que le
courtier est choisi il va négocier il va
chercher en jouant sur toutes les toutes
les assurances le pr les meilleures
conditions pour pour son client donc
tant qu'on aura la MO qui ne peut pas
négocier lui et le courtier de l'autre
côté on a une
relation pas malsine mais une relation
inhabituelle qui fait sortir le courtier
de son rôle traditionnel il est plus au
service du client enfin son client c'est
plus à nous et c'est ça qui embêtant
pour
nous je termine sur deux choses assez
brièvement je pense que c'est le chemin
qui me semble moi le peut-être le plus
intéressant sur lequel travailler je
suis ravi comme vous l'avez pas ça va me
permettre de une plusvalue sur votre
intervention qui était qui était
complète c'est la question de la
mutualisation euh il y a plusieurs
manières de mutualiser et si on veut
intéresser les assurances au risque à
notre risque des collectivités locales
il faut probablement aller sur une
mutualisation de nos risques alors il y
a plusieurs chemins il y a la
mutualisation géographique pourrais dire
par exemple que à l'échelle d'une région
pas forcément le périmètre de la d'un
conseil régional mais d'un d'une zone
géographique à l'échelle d'une région
des collectivités se coordonnent elle
pourra pour avoir une collectivité pivot
par exemple qui serait le conseil
régional comme on disait tout à l'heure
qui a une force de frappe plus
importante je suis pas absolument
convaincu que ce soit le meilleur schéma
parce que là vous rentrez dans une zone
géographique et donc on aurait une une
sinistralité simultanée he quand vous
avez les événements qu'on vient de
connaître dans le P de calis si tout le
monde est dans le même bloc mutualisé du
pcalis tout le monde a le même problème
simultanément et donc je sais pas si
c'est le meilleur chemin vous pourriez
avoir je parle devant une spécialiste
des villes touristiques on pourrait
avoir un bloc un bloc par par spécific
les communes de littoral les communes de
montagne il y aurait des
problématiques il y aurait des
problématiques homogènes mais pas la
même géographie ce qui permettrait pas
avoir une simultanéité des sinistres je
me demande néanmoins j'en viens à ma
conclusion à ce stade he c'est pas
définitif je me demand moins si une
mutualisation par strat n'aurait pas du
sens avec les mêmes types de
problématiques les régions on a les
mêmes problèmes on se parle on a
l'habitude de se
parler on a on a les mêmes lycées à à à
à protéger on a a les mêmes
problématiques les départements ont les
mêmes problématiques et par strat de
commune on peut retrouver des des des
similitudes peut-être que si on avançait
vers la mutualisation pour avoir des
chemins il y a plein de métiers qui à un
moment donné vous savez il y a le monde
de la nuit les boîtes de nuit les
casinos ces chosesl étaient devenu
inassurable il y a 20 25 ans plus
personne ne voulait y aller et un jour
des gens se sont mis sur le marché on
dit en fait on va on va fédérer tous ces
acteurs là ils ont pris tous les acteurs
ils sont dit par la mutualisation on va
réintéresser les assurances et on va se
dire à un moment donné le marché devient
voilà intéressant pour eux actif donc
moi je si je peux mettre une par rapport
à tout ce que vous avez dit et que je
partage peut-être réfléchir aussi à
cette piste de la mutualisation par
strat de de collectivité et dernier
point et c'est vraiment mon dernier il
faut absolument et ça a été parfaitement
dit qu'on réinvente la la qu'on par
qu'on réinvente qu'on invente un métier
dans nos collectivités qui est celle du
risque management toutes les entreprise
aujourd'hui pratique le risque
management c'est-à-dire d'avoir une
prévention une gestion des risques en
amont de toute nature c'est pour ça le
cyber c'est quand même intéressant parce
qu'aujourd'hui 42 % des attaques cyber
concernent des collectivités locales on
n'est pas prémuni là-dessus et il y a
des choses à construire nos flotte
automobile à un moment donné ça peut
aussi passer par une formation des
agents bénéficiaires de ces véhicules
sur quelques process assez simple quand
on voit qu'un gymnase à gravelg il y a
un peu plus d'un mois a brûlé
intégralement est parti comme en fait
paille en quelques heures on peut se
dire aussi qu'il faut repenser la
manière dont on construit les bâtiments
on le fait pour le nouveau bâtiment mais
il y a il y a des choses à refaire sur
il y a connaître notre patrimoine et
comment corriger des choses dans notre
patrimoine pour que tout ne brûle pas
quand vous parlait de feu de poubelle
tout à l'heure bah à un moment donné
quand on met des couvercles sur des
Benes bah d'un seul coup les feuills
partent moins c'est des petites choses
et vous savez si on réinvente je parlais
tout à l'heure cette relation avec l'AMO
et avec le courtier l'agent
l'intermédiaire si on invente une
relation commerciale en amant au moment
où on discute et on fait on intègre la
prévention et la gestion des risques
dans l'élaboration de notre police
d'assurance ça va changer énormément de
choses parce que du coup on va le
construire ensemble le définir ensemble
on sera pas dans des automatismes et on
va inventer de nouveaux contrats
d'assurance et qui auront du coup plus
d'assurance sur le marché avec lesqueles
on pourra travailler et ré instaurer
cette concurrence qui est le seul moyen
d'arriver au juste prix de l'assurance
je vous
remercie merci euh beaucoup messieurs
donc cette audition elle se passe bien
dans le cadre de la mission
d'information de la commission des
finances du Sénat donc il n'a pas qui
n'a pas éid enfin qui a son propre
périmètre et et ses propres désidérata
et donc je donne la parole je donnerai
la parole à franise Gatel après mais
d'abord à son rapporteur général qui est
rapporteur de la mission d'information
Jean-François yon oui merci merci
monsieur le Président je veux vous
remercier tous les trois je je veux
d'abord rappeler que on
ouvre pour un temps qui va être rapide
c'est en gros 6 semaines pour essayer
d'être dans la concordance du calendri
rier et je
vous je veux également préciser que nous
avions nous avons évidemment invité
l'association des département de France
qui n'a malheureusement pas pu
libérer un de ses élus pour nous
rejoindre mais il y aura une
contribution c'est pour poser les choses
au départ la deuxième je vais peut-être
moi revenir un peu sur l'objectif et la
méthode la méthode elle est de partir
d'un
diagnostic sur les difficultés d'où le
questionnaire j'insiste sur le
questionnaire rappelez qu'il y a le
questionnaire qui a été envoyé à toutes
les collectivités en tous les cas toutes
les communes chacun d'entre vous en tant
que membre de la commission des finances
a
reçu copie d'une lettre qu'il peut
utiliser évidemment et je vous invite à
l'utiliser à l'endroit des maire
notamment de vos communes mais également
des présents interco et en général ça
peut ensuite énerver les syndicats
divers et multiples déchets scolaires
parce qu'il y a aussi ce sujet on a à ce
jour donc c'est du 1emer ou 28 février
euh utiliser la le le le site
participation.senat.fr ce matin nous
avions enregistré 324 réponses pourquoi
j'insiste parce que c'est le seul
dispositif qui va
amener par notre démarche une
entrée de manière
double le cas par cas
elle est remontée par les association
qui feront des éléments de synthèse on
prend on laisse on suit on partage on en
prend une partie parce que l'idée
d'abord d'avoir un diagnostic le plus
objectif possible et
partagé
j'entends qu'à priori c'est tous les
éléments dont je dispose également
jusqu'à maintenant c'est plutôt de dire
que c'est plutôt des territoires plus
urbains qui sont majoritairement
concernés alors vous voyez la lutte du
petit contre le gros le rural contre
face à l'urbain comme quoi parfois
certains estiment que le rural est
oublié maltraité là on s'aperçoit que
c'est plutôt
dans dans le monde urbain que le sujet
des collectivités est davantage
exposé et pourtant j'ai des retours
aussi assez contrasté donc nous verrons
raison pour laquelle il faut s'extraire
de son petit périmètre essayer d'avoir
la vision nationale ça c'est le premier
sujet le le moi je veux donc sur l'état
des des des difficultés et je vais avoir
trois séries de de questions un
justement sur le diagnostic et vraiment
je je pense que il faut insister sur
l'importance de ce temps de du
diagnostic et donc du porter à
connaissance de le sujet des ressources
et trois le sujet des solutions et je le
dis moi je c'est l'ouverture donc j'ai
pas de j'ai j'ai bien des idées mais
çaen est CEN est là et je n'ai
absolument rien d'arrêté et notre
rapport aura d'autant plus d'intérêt
qu'il fera la meilleure Sy
possible de la problématique des
assurances donc sur les les difficultés
rencontrées par les collectivités moi ce
qui m'intéresse r aujourd'hui ou dans
une contribution complémentaire c'est
peut-être que vous nous donniez le
quantitatif de problème de réponse un
appel d'offre problème de hausse
diverses et multiples coout des
franchises Haus comment
dirais-je très
inhabituel très hors norme des des des
des coûts effectivement des contrats ou
des franchises parfois des
indumnisations qui tardent pour ne pas
dire des résiliations brutal je me
permets juste de vous dire que pour moi
un contrat sinalagmatique il est des
droits et devoirs et chacun à la liberté
de sans défaire et en général selon des
comment dirais-je sans qui est c'est
vrai malheureusement toujours de
justification d'îné mais c'est c'est la
liberté du contrat et à titre personnel
j'y suis attaché mais ça c'est CIT un
petit aparté deuxième sujet sur les
difficultés rencontrées est-ce qu'elle
touche j'ai beaucoup entend parler des
des dommages au bien ou de l'assurance
auto est-ce qu'elle touche aussi la
protection des agents et des élus en
tous les cas aujourd'hui et puis
troisième élément quel est l' viis des
uns des autres j'ai entendu des choses
hein sur
l'autoassurance la
mutualisation cible et ou aller jusqu'à
des captives quand on va dans les
captives c'est encore autre chose voilà
on précisera mais voilà je je fais des
questions volontairement ouvertes ça
c'est plutôt sur les l'enjeu de ce que
vous de ce que les collectivités
rencontrent chacune dans leur périmètrre
sur les ressources
question pensez-vous que les
collectivités ont selon leur taille et
conf tion les ressources humaines
techniques et ou financières et
budgétaire
pour bien pouvoir répondre aux
conditions de souscription des contrats
ou de leur
évolution donc c'est ce qu'on a évoqué
qu' des charges appel d'offr enfin et
cetera les collectivités doivent-ell
d'ailleurs imaginer des des des
formation
amélioré par rapport à ce qui existe ou
qui n'existe pas pas actuellement vous
paraissent d'ailleurs tel les les
collectivités être bien informé et en
capacité donc d'avoir leur personnel sur
l'ensemble des risques d'assurance
climatique émeute le risque cyber qui
est un risque émergent euh dans tous les
cas moi j'ai bien j'ai bien intégré
depuis le début qu' que nous devions y
veiller le sujet des inondations voilà
j'en parle pas donc de de enfin j'en
parle au contraire de elle manière
éventuellement s'il y a des
insuffisances aujourd'hui
amélioré l'idée n'est pas de mettre un
carcan d'obligation de contrainte c'est
juste d'avoir l'état des lieux enfin ce
qu'il faut quand même il fara aussi
qu'on prenne garde de ne pas ajouter de
la complexité là où on
demande du bon sens de la simplicité
dans les rapports de la facilité pour
contractualiser donc mais ça ça ça veut
dire qu'àun moment on sera quand même
confronté à
cette à cet enjeu et puis peut-être le
le le le dernier élément c'est de deux
quels sont à votre avis les les risques
qui
demain pèseront le plus
sur les biens des collectivités j'ai
parlé d'un certain nombre de risques
climatiques j'ai j'avais pas évoqué mais
je l'évoque puisque maintenant on sent
que des risques que je vais appeler pour
l'instant de type
émeut peuvent avoir des coûts
importants et ils ne sont pas forcément
traité de la même façon s'ils sont s'ils
surviennent de manière isolée ou si
c'est pendant une séquence de quelques
jours voilà ça n'obéit pas non plus
forcément en tous les cas sera pas la
même indemnisation selon les cas donc et
puis bah peut-être vous avez évoqué
c'est peut-être pas aujourd'hui la la
problématique de de
l'attractivité qu'il faut redonner au
marché parce que je crois plutôt à ça
aussi moi pour que les assureurs y
reviennent
euh je partage une partie du diagnostic
pour tout vous dire je ne crois pas du
tout que les entreprises et toutes des
risques managers je veux juste vous
rappeler souvenez-vous ce qui ce qui
s'est produit quand il y a eu la crise
sanitaire vous prenez juste un risque le
risque perdre d'exloitation il n'est
même pas souscrit par la moitié des
entreprises VO c'est et en général si
vous souscrivez pas vous avez TR chance
sur qu de pas vous en remettre
donc c'est pas c'est pas ni de la
responsabilité ni de la culpabilité il
faut effectivement je pense qu'on
progresse et donc peut-être si si vous
avez des avis aujourd'hui ou à nous
communiquer entre maintenant et et je
dirais pour nous euh un gros mois début
mars pour pouvoir intégrer les éléments
de proposition euh des collectivités
parce que c'est quand même intéressant
d'avoir à la
fois je dira l'éventail des situations
euh dans leur diversité et d'avoir aussi
une une production par les les
associations d'élus sur le sujet pour
faire en sorte que on améliore les
choses avec des tarifs soutenables et
puis peut-être je le redis une part
d'autoassurance ou
d'organisation c'est pas impossible ça
fait partie des réflexions certains
disent le risque agricole c'est bien
réformé faudra-t-il le faire moi je
crois qu'il manque et là où on va aussi
nous mettre beaucoup l'accent c'est sur
la connaissance que peuvent
avoir les réassureurs norm notamment qui
eux tournent ou font tourner un certain
nombre de modèles alors sur des c'est
plutôt sur des événements climatiques
les événements type émeute je suis pas
sûr qu'aujourd'hui on ait beaucoup de
recul sur la connaissance du sujet voilà
les les les les éléments messieur que je
voulais en tous les cas porter à votre
connaissance et en question pour ouvrir
le bal merci monsieur le rapporteur
général alors pour la bonne organisation
je pense qu'on va prendre toutes les
prises de parole et que vous
répondrez globalement aux questions tous
les trois à la fin sachant que j'ai six
inscrits pour l'instant et donc il en
reste 5 et comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure je passe la parole à la
présidente
Gatel cherche le bouton
merci ah c'est pas le
B voilà
merci aux
finances ah oui je suis pas une femme
d'argent pardon alors je je passe donc
je voulais vous remercier d'abord très
sincèrement je voulais vous
remercier voilà de cette initiative
extrêmement importante
puisque régulièrement dans les
consultations qui sont faites sur le
recueil des principales préoccupations
des élus la question des assurances
arrive aujourd'hui parfois dans le top 3
d'une manière beaucoup plus forte
qu'avant même si cela a été dit on sait
que si les risque je veux dire si le
climat en terme de météo mais aussi le
climat social agrave et augmente les
risques on sait qu'il y a une situation
un peu structurelle donc merci beaucoup
de cette initiative qui intéresse
beaucoup notre délégation collectivité
merci de
l'invitation qui est faite à la
délégation moi je me réjouis toujours
quand on est assez porureux entre nous
pour être efficace et
échanger je je remercie des témoignages
moi je seraai assez rapide sur les
constats que l'on fait parce que nous
partageons totalement ce qui a été dit
par les représentant des des des
associations le diagnostic qu' le
connaît effectivement je pense que ça
n'est pas une opposition entre strat de
commune pour parler des communes mais
entre nature de commune c'est celles qui
ont des équipements d'école des des des
équipements sportifs et d'autres qui ne
ne l'ont pas mais c'est une
préoccupation assez assez générale et la
question Alain chrétien l'évoqué c'est
l'acceptabilité la
soutenabilité euh de l'assurance pour
les collectivités il y a des leviers et
moi j'y suis sensible vous avez parlé de
l'évolution du bon usage du code des
marchés publics et ça ça me paraît
important
l'ingénierie aujourd'hui aller acheter
de l'assurance c'est un vrai métier euh
c'est un peu comme dans les centrales
d'achat dans la grande distribution quoi
c'est un métier particulier où en face
on a des gens très affutés les
collectivités ne le sont pas et qu'il
est très important d'être accompagné en
ingénierie à condition avant et tu l'as
dit Alain d'avoir fait un diagnostic de
la situation et ça c'est rarement fait
dans nos collectivité on n' pas
l'habitude moi je crois beaucoup à la
mutualisation sous des formes diverses
et variées c'est parfois à l'échelle des
interc où là on a une capacité à
négocier voilà qui est bien ça peut être
par catégorie communes qui ont les mêmes
ris mais je crois aux mutualisation avec
un S dans toutes les formes à condition
qu'elle soit
pertinente ça c'est important et on a vu
sur un autre sujet l'énergie où
aujourd'hui on a des collectivité qui se
regroupe pour former un syndicat d'achat
d'énergie et je trouve que ça c'est
plutôt pas mal c'est parfois l'échelle
d'un département mais c'est toutes les
collectivités parce qu'il ne faut pas
enlever aux collectivités leur capacité
à maîtriser aussi leur politique
d'assurance enfin un mot sur le risque
alors vous avez raison il faut qu'on
apprenne à gérer le risque mais il
faudra l'expliquer à nos concitoyens euh
parce que je veux dire le sujet d'un
maire c'est que vous avez un un but de
foot qui tombe un panneau de basket vous
avez une judiciarisation dans notre
société qui fait que nos concitoyens ils
cherchent le coupable qui est forcément
responsable et donc ça amène à de la
surencher et quand on a inscrit dans la
Constitution le principe de précaution
je pense pas qu'on est rendu plus simple
le marché de l'assurance donc on a un
vrai sujet la culture du risque vous
l'avez dit c'est très important et ça
m'amène à parler et ce sera le dernier
point de la cybersécurité nous avons
fait à la délégation en 2021 en
partenariat avec la délégation aux
entreprise tout un travail sur la
cybersécurité et nous avons vu que la
cybersécurité et les cyberattaques
touchent toutes les
collectivité demain matin ce sont des
usines d'eau potable qui seront
attaquées je parle pas des hôpitaux et
tout ça mais c'est énorme et que nous
n'avons aucune conscience aucune culture
du du risque et nous avons auditionné
des collectivités petites et grandes qui
ont été cyber attaqué pour donner un
tout petit exemple pour montrer la
gravité des choses on a quand même une
aglo très
importante et des communes qui pendant
10 jours à cause de cyberattaque n'ont
pas pu délivrer de permis d'inhumer je
raconte que ça euh voilà et donc sur la
cyber sécurité je pense qu'il faut que
les associations d'élus et les préfets
soient très proactif pour voir si les
collectivité dans toute leur diversité
sont conscients et que sont prémunis et
que si on a un plan de gestion de risque
comme on a des plans communaau de
sauvegarde des pprrii je pense que aussi
on
diminuerait un peu le risque et que donc
je pense que ça limiterait peut-être les
besoins d'assurance en tout cas les les
les surcouts merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup Françoise Gatel
alors la parole est maintenant à marc
Laménie et puis ensuite j'aurai
natthalie
Goulet merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général et merci
à nos trois invités pour leur
témoignages bon qui nous permettent
vraiment de nous éclairer sur des des
situations qui sont vraiment très très
complexe moi je parlerai ma modeste
expérience comme ma un village il y a
quelques années euh dans les ardenes et
c'est vrai que moi j'ai repris
historiquement notre assureur vous les
avez cité bon group Hama bon c'est vrai
que les contrats sont relativement
simples mais c'est vrai que vous avez
accès sur alors comment comment peut-on
faire parce que l'état du patrimoine
immobilier vous l'avez rappeler que même
à l'échelle d'un village c'est très
compliqué parce que sur on lit les
contrats euh bah on on met telle salle
telle petite salle t l'église ENF bon
voilà les les principaux bâtiments à
l'échelle d'un village moi j'ai raisonné
surtout à l'échelle d'un village et et
en réalité c'est
très c'est c'est très succin bon c'est
vrai que on n pas eu ces problèmes là
parce que on touche du bois on sollicite
très peu je dirais l'assureur puisque
bon je dirais on on a très peu de de
désordre si on peut le dire et c'est pas
comparable avec les grandes grande
collectivité alors sur l'état de
patrimoine immobilier réellement
qu'est-ce que on on peut faire
et et puis ma ma dernière question c'est
je dirais il y a des des banques qui
faisaient que banque et qui se
transforme aussi en plus en assureurs et
viceversa les assureurs qui deviennent
banquiers donc je dirais comment tout ça
peut fonctionner notamment dans dans les
appels d'offrees pour surtout pour les
grosses collectivités je merci
beaucoup merci Marc laméi Nathalie
Goulet et puis ensuite la parole sera à
Éric Boquet euh oui monsieur le
Président bon d'abord je voudrais
évidemment remercier les les
intervenants sur un un constat qu'on
qu'on
partage moi je voudrais savoir quel est
l'analy de nos voisins européens parce
qu'on on n'est pas les seuls à avoir des
collectivités et puis pour travailler
sur d'autres sujets notamment liés à la
sécurité je voudrais savoir si on a
pensé ou si on pourrait éventuellement
imaginer
d'utiliser le fond qui est destiné à la
sécurité il y a un Fond Européen d'un
milliard et des poussières avec 98
millions réservés à la France qui est
notamment consacré à la protection des
sites à la protection des biens et
cetera voir un certain nombre
d'opérations de protection par exemple
sur les émeutes mais aussi sur alors
pour le coup pour le risque
cyber et donc je comprends la la version
locale de l'intercommunalité de la
mutualisation et cetera mais peut-être
que sur un sujet aussi important on
pourrait on pourrait voir un peu au
niveau européen ce qui se passe parce
qu'il y a quand même des budgets forts
et une organisation qui qui rentre aussi
de façon tout à fait pertinente en terme
de
concurrence puisque puisque les les
assureurs doivent être mis en
concurrence au terme aussi des des
règlements européens et à ma
connaissance mais j'ai jamais été élu
local donc je suis bien mal placé
mais je pense pas qu' est une close
jamais même pas conseiller municipal de
camamber celle qui va c'est dommage pour
Cambert mais mais en attendant en
attendant je pense pas qu'il a une
clause de nationalité en ce qui concerne
les assureurs des collectivités je pense
que les les dispositifs européens
devraient fonctionner et et je me
demande si la mission que que nous
conduisons ne devrait pas aussi nous
conduire vers Bruxelles pour voir si
notamment ces fonds spécifiques ne
pourrai pas être utilisés à cet effet
merci merci Nathalie Goulet la parole
est à Éric Boquet puis ça sera Florence
blatrix conta oui merci monsieur le
Président je vis d'abord remercier nos
intervenants j'ai trouvé leur discours
extrêmement intéressant concret ancré
dans le réel et très sincèrement
j'ignorais à quel point il y avait un
sujet qui s'pposer avec autant de
violence pour certaines collectivités
moi je suis tj conseiller municipal d'un
village de 2000 habitants en métropole
lilloise où le l'assurance n'est pas un
sujet aujourd'hui voilà on a un budget
de fonctionnement d' 15 et la PR
multirisque c'est 12000 voilà il y a pas
de sujet donc je découvre vraiment que
dans certains coins ça ça cogne des
abandons de de contrats et cetera alors
je crois que vous disiez que le chiffre
d'affaires de l'assurance c'est 220
milliards c'est ça grosso modo et dedans
1 ou 2 % pour les collectivités ok donc
un petit segment du l'activité de
l'assurance euh et j'ai regardé un peu
le les les documents de la Banque de
France sur le les investissements des
assureurs nous notre commune est assurée
chez AXA on n'est pas à l'mac Lig group
on est dans le privé enfin entre
guillemets AA et les assureurs
aujourd'hui les en cours de placement
enfin à fin mars 2023 était à 2422
milliards
d'euros 2422 milliards d'euros 90 % du
PIB en augmentation de 53 milliards au
premier trimestre de l'an dernier donc
voyez on est très très très très loin
des franchises de 10 millions des
risques à couvrir et
cetera donc les assureurs sont également
financeurs de la dette publique ça veut
dire qu'ils ont une garantie d'avoir les
intérêts payés chaque année cette année
ça sera 51 milliards 52 milliards qui se
partageront avec d'autres investisseurs
bien sûr mais donc il y a une rente
garantie d'argent public enfin je veux
dire j'entendeit que les assurances
choisissaient de se désengager de la
couverture du risque des collectivités
je pense que c'est un choix c'est un
choix de gestion et est-ce qu'il serait
pas temps de demander au aux assureurs
de se de revenir à leur cœur de métier
couvrir le risque assurer le risque je
comprends qu'ils puisse investir ils
font partie de ce qu'on appelle les unin
les investisseurs institutionnel avec
les banques et cetera mais leur premier
métier c'est l'assurance la couverture
du risque donc je suis vraiment choqué
de ce désengagement délibéré unilatéral
des assurances parce queell vont faire
de l'argent ailleurs qui leur
permettrait largement de faire face au
risques présent et àenir
merci merci Éric Boquet la parole est à
Florence blatrix contta puis ce sera
Madame Christine
Lavarde merci monsieur le Président
merci aux trois intervenants en effet
qui nous ont éclairé sur cette
problématique moi-même élu d'une petite
commune rurale je n'ai encore pas ces
difficultés là euh est-ce que à terme
vous pensez que les communes les plus
petites peuvent aussi par effet de
domino
être concerné par ces difficultés
d'assurance c'était le premier point et
le deuxième point vous avez évoquer un
panier minimum d'assurance pouvez-vous
nous en dire un peu plus sur ce qu'il
pourrait intégrer et est-ce qu'il
n'implique pas une part finalement
d'auto-assurance on le voit avec
l'augmentation des franchises est-ce que
on ne va pas vers un mix assurance
auto-assurance des collectivités je vous
remercie merci beaucoup donc la parole
est à Madame Christine avarne et ensuite
ce sera Isabelle briquet
oui merci monsieur le Président donc à
plusieurs reprise vous êtes vous avez
mentionné en fait le besoin d'un d'un
rôle de l'État ou de la puissance
publique pour venir palier la
défaillance du secteur privé aujourd'hui
cet acteur public il existe c'est le BCT
le bureau central de tarification qui
doit proposer une solution d'assurance à
toute personne qui s'est vu opposer un
refus par le par le secteur privé donc
est-ce que vous avez eu connaissance de
proposition techniques faites par le BCT
est-ce que les
conditions sont entre guillemets
insurmontable pour les collectivités qui
en ont bénéficié ou est-ce qu'elles sont
dans la même épure que ce qu'aurait pu
offrir le secteur privé et donc j'en
arrivé à la conclusion qu'en fait
l'offre du secteur public existe déjà ça
c'était ma ma première remarque ma
seconde question porte donc vous avez
chacun mentionné des exemples
particulier de collectivités qui ont
fait l'objet d'une sorte d'antisélection
par leur assureur est-ce que vous avez
eu la possibilité de de creuser un peu
pour essayer de comprendre en fait ce
phénomène d'antisélection dont elles
auraient été victime bah c'estd qu'en
fait elles ont été retirées du
portefeuille de sélection néga enfin
donc parce que derrière il peut y avoir
et c'est là où c'était intéressant quand
vous avez mis en avant le besoin de
développer la culture du risque
management dans les
collectivités c'est quelque chose qu'on
imagine pas très bien mais qui en fait
est
assez lié aussi à tout ce qui est la
certification des comptes enfin toute
cette démarche en fait et les communes
justement qui sont rentrer dans des
phases de certification elles sont aussi
obligées de de mettre en place une
véritable culture du risque et pas
uniquement euh maîtrise de du risque de
la chaîne comptable mais maîtrise de
l'ensemble de leur risqu euh pour
pouvoir prouver que elles sont euh voilà
elles enfin elles agissent de manière
complètement consciente sur tous les sur
tous les secteurs et euh donc ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose moi qui une idée
qui me semble très intéressante et
aujourd'hui pour vous quelle est la le
frein majeur est-ce que c'est uniquement
une question de moyens c'est-à-dire que
les collectivités ne peuvent pas allouer
des moyens pour mettre en place cet
agent supplémentaire qui deviendra
risque manager est-ce que c'est un
problème de disponibilité de personnes
formées à cette culture et adapter aussi
à la culture des collectivités parce
qu'on le voit bien pareil si je continue
mon ma comparaison avec la certification
c'est pas la même chose de certifier les
comptes d'une entreprise et de certifier
les comptes d'une collectivité c'est pas
la même chose de gérer le risque d'une
entreprise et de gérer le risque d'une
collectivité publique voilà merci
beaucoup madame Lavarde donc la parole
est à Isabelle briquet et ensuite ça
sera gisline
Sonet merci président donc tout d'abord
je tiens moi aussi à remercier no nos
intervenants parce qu'on voit
qu'effectivement c'est c'est du vécu
c'est un vécu que je que je partage
puisque dans dans mon département il y a
beaucoup de de soucis ne serait-ce que
dans la commune que dont j'ai été maire
pendant de nombreuses années où les
contrats ont proposés augmentent de 70 %
donc c'est c'est assez prohibitif mais
j'ai envoyé je au rapporteur j'ai envoyé
le le la lettre et join le lien pour
répondre au questionnaire il y a déjà
des retours et j'ai été appelé un
certain nombre de fois depuis le début
de la semaine on est que mercredi donc
il y a bien un un véritable souci je
voudrais juste revenir sur la la culture
du risque vous en avait tous parlé donc
j'entends bien qu'il faut progresser
pour les collectivités sur ce sur cette
question
néanmoins il y a quand même une légère
contradiction avec le fait que les les
collectivités les élus sont responsables
d'absolument tout et cette
judiciarisation qu'on qu'on voit
croître tout le
temps ça me paraît ça me paraît un peu
une contradiction qu'il va falloir quand
même
gérer et et d'autre part autant pour les
plus grosses collectivités euh je je
peux l'appréhender pour les pour les
plus petites ça sans doute quand même
poser une difficulté donc je voudrais
voir un petit peu votre avis là-dessus
et par ailleurs mais j'ai j'ai peut-être
mal compris sur les relations à Mo
courtier dont vous dont vous avez
parlé moi dans mes souvenirs j'ai fait
appel directement à un courtier pour
pour trouver mes assurances et j'ai pas
eu ce souci là enfin j'ai pas eu de
souci et le courtier était bien
le client c'était bien la collectivité
et j'ai pu avoir à l'époque des des
contrats intéressant contrat d'ailleurs
qui malheureusement on été bien remis en
cause sous la depuis que je ne suis plus
de en activité enfin je ne suis plus de
ma commune donc si vous pouviez me
préciser les choses parce que j'ai sans
doute une petite incompréhension de ma
part merci merci chers collègues la
parole est à G et ensuite on terminera
noralement par Jean-Marie maison très
bien je vais essayer d'être d'être la
plus brève possible parce que je crois
qu'il y a
énormément effectivement de commentaires
à faire sur sur sur ce sujet moi j'ai
peut-être trois points la gestion du
risque en fait elle est de plus en plus
prignante au sein des collectivités
qu'elle soit grande ou petite enfin moi
j'ai été mère d'une commune qui avait un
PPR un plan de prévention pour risque
sur les cavités souterraines pendant 12
ans je me suis interrogé en disant
comment je j'anticipe le sujet on sait
que de toute façon les carrières de Gys
un jour demain dans 100 ans dans 300 ans
elles vont s'effondrer et et et ma
commune est directement concerné puisque
nous avons quand même des endroits alors
c'est pas des habitations hein le PPR a
fait a fait son œuvre mais il y a quand
même des endroits où on sait que la
voirie peut à tout moment s'effondrer
apparaître un fontier et donc je crois
que de plus en plus et notamment face à
la réaction des des assurances
aujourd'hui on a cette cette cette cette
vision ce besoin de pouvoir anticiper
mais en fait actuellement les
collectivités n'en ont pas les moyens
parce que problème d'ingénierie on l'a
on l'a déjà dit ba des dotations enfin
bon tout ça on sait ce qu'il en est mais
en tout cas si on doit travailler
aujourd'hui dans la gestion des risques
il faut effectivement faire faire un
inventaire un vrai diagnostic tant sur
les biens que sur tous les risques
autour les PPR les risques industriels
qui qui ont aussi voilà impactent
forcément forcément les territoires et
parf fois les biens même si c'est pas à
la charge des collectivités mais on a on
a cette question la question des des
pollutions l'impact sur la santé humaine
en fait on est face aujourd'hui
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé un
vrai problème structurel sur lequel il
va falloir anticiper et aujourd'hui on
voit bien que les assurances sur une
niche particulière se rend compent de
l'ampleur du travail et je crois que
l'année dernière lorsqu'ils ont fait
leur leur envoie intempestif et assez
brutal il faut le dire à certaines
commune je pense que ça a été vraiment
euh voilà un moyen d'alerter en tout cas
sur sur les les problématiques sur
lesquelles n nous sommes confronté donc
moi il me semble important que dans le
diagnostic on intègre et à la fois vous
l'avez souligné les enfin la la bonne
connaissance de la réalité de de auquel
les communes ont été confrontées par
rapport à leur à leurs problèmes
d'assurance mais je crois aussi qu'il
faut euh qu'on aille jusqu'à euh établir
la réalité c'est-à-dire quel est le
poids finalement aujourd'hui des
indemnités qui ont été enfin des charges
de la charge d'assurance qui a été
assumée par les collectivités et
finalement le montant des indemnités
mais ça je pense qu'on pourra interroger
directement les associations euh des
assurance pour avoir euh un peu de
visibilité sur sur sur sur finalement
quel quel est le poids et et et et et
rappeler en tout cas que leur métier
c'est bien leur cœur de métier c'est
bien l'assurance et que à un moment
donné il faut effectivement gérer euh
gérer ce risque euh et et et ne pas se
défausser moi je veux bien qu'on rendre
le marché plus attractif hein euh et
évidemment qu'il faut que que on arrive
à faire en sorte que une bonne fois pour
toutes les les collectivités puissent se
être être assuré dans dans dans dans
dans leur bien mais quelque part il faut
aussi leur leur rappeler
leur leurs devoirs et leur leur travail
pour l'intérêt général on parle beaucoup
de comment aujourd'hui on doit faire
société comment on doit confronter
collectivement les choses moi je
rappelle que lorsqu'on voit des sociétés
d'assurance qui gagnent effectivement
beaucoup d'argent à quel moment nous
collectivité état on on on impose alors
ça peut être le panier hein qui a été
minimal qui a été soulevé mais enfin il
me semble que il y a y a là aussi euh en
tout cas une alerte à faire il est
inadmissible que des collectivités qui
l'année dernière avaient des franchises
à 1500 € puissent tout d'un coup
recevoir un courrier où on leur annonce
que c'est plus 1500 mais c'est 1 million
d'euros en c'est c'est c'est quand même
moi je trouve enfin d'une d'une
brutalité euh extraordinaire donc je
crois que dans dans dans le diagnostic
il y a vraiment énormément de choses à
pouvoir à pouvoir palier moi je trouve
que les solutions en tout cas les enjeux
que vous avez posé sont sont sont sont
sont vraiment finalement les Aes sur
lequels nous devons nous devons
travailler la culture du risque oui mais
all jusqu'au bout et et profitons
finalement de cette opportunité dans les
collectivités pour pouvoir faire ce
diagnostic des biens réels qui nous
permettra d'ailleurs dans les petites
communes de pouvoir travailler sur nos
nos nos PPI puisque de toute façon c'est
notamment au travers de la transition
que nous devons porter sur les
territoires c'est vraiment une
opportunité pour pour pour les les
collectivités donc cette connaissance du
du patrimoine et puis travaillons de
toute façon sur sur les appels d'offres
parce que parce que pour les petites
collectivités c'est effectivement
toujours une grande difficulté mais il y
a un devoir là aussi de formation de de
meilleure connaissance et ça un lien
peut-être avec le statut le statut des
lit local sur lequel nous devons devons
travailler mais je je crois réellement
que là le Sénat se saisit d'unun d'un
sujet et on le voit au travers de vos
interventions qui qui est d'utilité
publique merci beaucoup jusen Sonet le
dernier inscrit à qui je passe la parole
est Jean-Marie
Mison merci monsieur le Président à mon
tour je voudrais remercier nos
intervenants pour la qualité et la
clarté de leurs prop
voyez-vous j'ai été maire pendant
plusieurs décennies il me semble que dès
le milieu des années 80 il y avait
s'agissant du marché des assurances une
situation
d'oligopole il avait déjà les deux
mastodante qu'on évoque y compris ce
matin et les autres ne s'intéressaient
pas trop même s'il y avait des
exceptions et je pense que cette
situation est
structurelle et peut-être que les autres
assurances ne sont sont pas penchés
intéressés au marché des collectivités
locales parce que précisément comme vous
le disiez les uns et les autres c'est
que les collectivités locales ne se
connaissent pas très bien leur
patrimoine ils savent que qu'ils ont une
gymnase une église mais au-delà le
contenu la définition particulière
précise de ces bâtiments n'est pas connu
et je pense que c'est une piste de
réflexion qu'il faut vers laquelle il
faut aller qui pourra peut-être amener à
d'autres assuran à s'intéresser j'ai
également une question parce que on en a
pas
parlé une question précise est-ce qu'on
sait combien il y a de compagnies
d'assurance en France on sait qu'il y en
a au moins deux mais est-ce qu'il y en a
d'autres mais c'est deux sur combien de
milliers très
peu plusieurs
dizaines merci président parfait merci
beaucoup c'est pas terminer par une
question extrêmement
précise moi du coup comme les échanges
ont été assez nourris je ne vais pas
reposer de question et je vais repasser
directement la parole alors en ordre
inversé et donc du coup on va commencer
par Éric chal et ensuite monsieur
franmentin et on terminera par vezou
merci alors j'ai essayé de de classer
les les questions il y en avait dans
toutes asimut comme les risque à couvrir
je vais peut-être commencer par par la
fin et pas pas pour le balayer mais la
manière dont vous avez
aborder votre proposition en tout cas le
chemin que vous tracez est aussi
révélateur deune conception de enfin de
l'économie et et et de la société moi je
encore une fois je si on se dit
que les assurances font plein d'argent
et que donc la moindre des choses c'est
qu'elle couvre le risque des
collectivités locales parce que les
collectivités locales ont une mission de
service public et donc elles ont qu'à
payer c'est pas le modèle économique
dans lequel je me place et si je vous
dis ça c'est pas par par par par
provocation si je vous le dis comme ça
c'est parce que parce que par que je
pense que en fait il serait
contreproductif à l'arrivée parce que
quand on raisonne comme ça en disant de
toute manière il y a un coup naturel
enfin ça doit être assuré de toute
manière et ben ce sera assuré de toute
manière mais à la fin encore une fois je
vous le dis la seule société qui pourra
le faire ce sera une société publique
totalement publ et ce sera impuissant
foond à l'arrivée parce que
parallèlement vous nous disiez ah oui
vous avez raison mais ça il faut faire
ça mais vous avez raison quand vous
dites qu'il faut aussi mieux prévenir
les risques mieux gérer et cetera mais à
partir du moment où vous savez que toute
manière vous êtes assuré à T plein que
votre franchiss son bas que votre votre
votre votre prime elle est pas élevée
comment allonsnous faire nous-mêmes
cette révolution de prévention et
gestion du risque quand on sait que de
toute manière à la fin c'est pas
vraiment moi qui paye donc je pense que
de toute manière l'idée de partir dans
cette relation de de économique elle est
importante et d'ailleurs je je ve pas
épiloguer là-dessus parce que c'est
c'est philosophique et on se convaincra
pas les uns les autres mais l'assurance
elle a toujours été privée dans dans
l'histoire elle n'est dans l'Italie
médiévale
et ça sert à assurer les bateaux qui qui
vont partir qui sortent du port et et
c'est il y a une logique de partage des
Bénéfic en fait à ce moment-là on se dit
ces bateaux qui vont partir vont faire
du commerce et vont faire du profit et
l'assureur se dit à un moment donné
tiens je vais prendre une part du profit
donc je je je crois vraiment qu'on on
est obligé de raisonner si on veut
baisser les prix c'est horrible ce que
je veux dire c'est c'est si on veut
baisser les prix il faut une concurrence
saine et et non faussée et et quand il y
a une entreprise publique qui a d'urance
et non Faé mais c'est c'est deux
logiques différentes donc je vais pas
épiloguer plus longtemps essayer de
recrouper les points ensemble il y avait
la question vous posiez la question tout
à l'heure de pardon vous posiez la
question des des des petites communes
est-ce qu'à un moment donné les petites
communes vont être touchées et
parallèlement madame lav n nous posiez
la question
de de pourquoi tel ou tel type de
collectivité notamment les grosses ont
été cblé au départ je pense qu'en fait
les deux questions se rejoignent c'est
pour ça que je les je les recoupe
ensemble le je parlais de la poule tout
à l'heure mais là c'est vraiment la la
poulée l'œuf dans un premier temps ces
sociétés d'assurance et mutuell qui ont
besoin de de redégager immédiatement des
marges parce qu'elles sont en grande
difficulté parce qu'elles ont assuré
tout le monde et la sinestralité explose
et et donc elles ont pas de situation
ell se retourne immédiatement vers ceux
dont elles se disent qu'elles vont
pouvoir faire immédiatement une marche
c'est plus facile de prendre beaucoup
d'argent pardon en c'est un peu comment
dire c'est un peu cavalier de la manère
don je le dis mais de faire une marge
très forte sur un très gros cl un très
gros assuré que d'aller prendre
individuellement les petites communes
mais ce ce ce cette
augmentation des primes cette
augmentation des franchises ça va
toucher tout le monde on s'attaque
d'abord au plus gros et c'est pour ça
que je fais pas forcément une nuance à
Monsieur rapporteur général vous disz à
un moment donné il y a peut-être le
milieu urbain et et un milieu plus rural
je crois pas que ce soit forcément ça je
pense qu'il y a les grosses
collectivités en taille et en budget et
et les autres et donc évidemment
mécaniquement pour le moment ce sont
plutôt les urbaines pour pour les
raisons qu'on vient d'évoquer mais
l'idée que d'autres collectivités
seraient épargn parce qu'elles sont en
zone moins tendu il y aura pas les mêmes
problèmes de de violence urbaine ou
autrre vous l'avez dit vous avez été
quand même touché alors que foi était
pas la première la première cible donc
je pense qu'on va y venir pourquoi les
grosses collectivités ont été toucher
parce que elles se sont dit
immédiatement dans leur négociation on
peut faire on peutire une marge
immédiate quand vous menacez une région
je monter donner les montants au début
mon intervention et pour les autres
régions je on vous les tiens à
disposition
lorsque vous faites simplement jouer sur
une seule région d'un seul coup vous
faites une marge très forte si vous
renégociez immédiatement votre contrat
mais en nuage de train vous allez avoir
la totalité des communes qui vont être
très très rapidement touchées je ne
pense pas que certaines soient exonérées
en raison de en raison en raison de leur
taille sur le risque management puisque
beaucoup de de de de questions sont sont
allées dessus c'est c'est pas une
solution unique en fait c'est une somme
de sujets sur lesquels il faut
travailler on dit disait vous disiez
madame la Présidente et à plusieurs fois
on a abordé la question de de la
juridiciarisation pardon j'ai ma langue
à fourché et mais c'est ça c'est une
tendance qui est inévitable la société
se judiciarise de plus en plus on le
sait nos concitoyens se retournent vers
nous donc la question c'est pas
simplement de vouloir s'en prémunir
refaire une loi Fauchon je le dis dans
cette maison qui sera encore plus
protectrice c'est c'est c'est de se dire
que de toute manière on est dans ce
cheminl et donc comment on fait pour
nous avoir un peu moins de risque c'est
des défauts de voirie c'est tout bête he
mais quand on réappréhende le défaut de
varie ça peut arriver sur même une
petite commune ça peut être une économie
assez substantielle assez assez
rapidement quand on forme les agents à
l'utilisation des véhicules on leur fait
pas repasser un service enfin le le le
le permis mais on on leur redonne
quelques codes quand vous utilisez un
véicule de fonction il y a tel ou tel
type de règles à respecter il y a plein
de petites choses comme ça ou ou des
choses plus vastes comme par exemple le
plan de sauvegarde communale vous avez
moins de 40 % des communes de France qu
un plan de sauvegarde communale il est
obligatoire uniquement pour les communes
en PPR pour les autres ça l'IT pas et on
le fait pas donc quand on se dit comme
ça entre nous oui mais oui c'est vrai il
faut qu'on s'intéresse au risque on se
le dit mais le moment venu il y a quand
même 40 % des communes qu'on pas un plan
de sauvegarde communal or c'est pas
simplement pour faire une économie
d'assurance que c'est important c'est
d'abord pour protéger nos administrés
parce que bien penser le plan de
sauvegarde communale c'est c'est se
prévenir de de risque d'inondation de
protection des populations et elle est
arrivé en fin de courses c'est prosaïque
mais c'est mais mais c'est aussi gagnant
financièrement parce que bien entendu
s'il y a moins de s s'il y a moins
d'accidentologie on sera gagnant sur sur
la la le coût de l'assurance à l'aré
mais c'est presque en à la fin du
processus le plus important c'est de
protéger la population évidemment c'est
ce qu'on fait tous mais voilà et j'en
viens à ce point de ce métier n'existe
pas vraiment aujourd'hui alors dans les
très grosses collectivités on a comme la
région on a des acheteurs des directeurs
des achats qui sont très compétents
c'est vraiment c'est des métiers
sensibles ils achètent tout tout Asim et
donc ce sont des gens qui on ont une
grande compétence mais on n pas
forcément dans toutes les collectivités
ce degré de connaissance et ce savoir
faire et même le directeur des achats le
plus compétent vous l'avez aussi dit
Françoise Gattel ils sont confrontés à à
à des assureurs dont c'est le métier au
quotidien et qui gère des choses
infiniment enfin ils ont l'habitude de
faire des choses plus compliquées que
des local donc ils peuvent aussi plus
facilement aller dans ces méandres et
les directeurs des achats peuvent être
perdu d'où d'où le recours à la MO et au
professionnels j'en viens à la nuance
alors quand vous dites moi j'ai pas eu
de problème parce que j'ai eu mon
courtier directement ben c'est
finalement par l'absurde la preuve que
ce système fonctionne vous voyez parce
que quand vous avez directement cette
relaction avec l'intermédiaire que c'est
que c'est votre agent d'assurance votre
courtier qui réfléchit avec vous et qui
construit le projet ben vous êtes dans
quelque chose qui est tout de suite sa
et vous me dites j'ai pas eu de problème
et vous avez en fait parfaitement raison
et moi je parleis de la situation o où
ces métiers se spécialisent où la MO un
peu comme allez j'allais dire un peu
comme knoc qui euh qui qui va va vous
vous prévenir de vos maladies euh et
tout tout toute personne bien pante est
un mal qui signore qui va euh
complexifier énormément le travail qui
va dire tu dois protéger Monsieur le
Maire vous devez protéger ça et puis et
ceci et cela et on va rentrer dans
quelque chose de plus en plus complexe
il fait son métier son métier c'est de
de d'élaborer la totalité des risques
hein et et donc il empile et euh et en
face vous avez ce ce courtier qui
souvent ben n'est plus que un opérateur
dans le champ qui se dit comment je peux
réintéresser au risque et donc en fait
il va plutôt réfléchir à mutualiser des
assureurs voir avec eux comment
travailler quand on n'est pas dans la
situation la plus brutal ou ça Arve
aussi parfois hein vous tombez
immédiatement enfin le le marché s
tellement complexifié que du coup de
toute façon votre appel d'offre il sera
de toute manière infructueux et on ne
revient à ce qu'on se disait à mot
couvert au début qu'on finit dans du gré
àé et euh et puis euh voilà la Moo et le
courtier en face vont vont discuter mais
la collectivité sort sort de est moins
défendu dans ce cas-là voilà donc pardon
j'étais un peu moins clair peut-être sur
ce dernier point le je termine làdessus
par que c'était votre première question
donc moi aussi je je suis retourné de la
fin au au début vous demandiez quels
étaient les risques qui pouvaient
augmenter dans le futur je je j'aimerais
comment dire être parfaitement au au
clair là-dessus
évidemment les les risques climatiques
ont des conséquences considérables et
ils vont aller croissant donc on on voit
bien que c'est c'est un enjeu majeur
mais vous avez vous avez des choses
aussi qui sont a priori comme ça on n
pas mentionné même le mot aujourd'hui
mais ça coûte extrêmement cher pour les
collectivités locales c'est la lutte
contre l'absentéisme et ça c'est c'est
croissant mais à la fin c'est pris en
charge par par par les assurances il les
courtiers d'assurance don c'est la la
spécialité de prendre de prendre en
charge voilà de prendre de prendre en
charge cet absentéisme ça fait partie
des choses qui probablement à un moment
donné vont plus pouvoir être assuré he
quand on parlait de panier minimum je
laisserai répondre à l' sur le sur le
sur le panier minimum pour pas être trop
long mais là typiquement on est dans une
ça on voit le chemin que suivent toutes
les collectivités enfin d'ailleurs c'est
pas propre au service public hein
mais l'absentéisme mais on voit le
chemin que ça prend ça va aller
évidemment croissant et ça on le voit
pas parce que c'est une somme de petits
coûts mais c'est des dépenses
considérables à l'arrivée donc ça ça va
aller croissant par
exemple merci beaucoup monsieur chal et
du coup la parole est à Thomas Fromentin
oui donc bah tout d'abord merci pour ces
échanges nourris parce que ça montre à
quel point il y avait effectivement
sal oui benah oui oui écoutez je trouve
à FO ah oui oui oui vous seriez très
bien accueilli à fois je vous y invite
avec avec grand plaisir
euh juste alors évidemment moi je encore
une fois je suis pas spécialiste et euh
et puis je pense qu'alin chrétien en
plus
euh répondra peut-être plus précisément
que moi-même donc juste quelques
remarques moi je veux juste nous dire un
peu un peu collectivement que
on parle des mécaniques du monde de
l'assurance de la des difficultés de ce
monde de l'assurance des logiques de
réassurance du fait qu'il n'y a plus de
logique concurrentielle et cetera et
cetera au bout du bout on a des
collègues dont on peut dire qu'il faut
augmenter la technicité et cetera et
cetera qui veulent juste assurer leur
bâtiment avec des logique de dommage
ouvrage donc c'est bien de leur dire que
le monde est complexe que tout ça la
concurrence est compliqué tout ça mais
au bout d'un moment dommage ou bien
pardon mais que ou dommage ou bien mais
que voilà enfin au bout d'un moment faut
aussi enfin comment dire essayer
d'apporter des solutions peut-être un
peu un peu simple et
comprendre la difficulté qui qui qui est
la l'heure et en gros on tourne autour
me semble-t-il d'une question peu
importe le mot dont on en parle c'est de
se dire dans effectivement dans un
marché qui est de moins en moins
concurrentiel quelle régulation quelle
régulation passe parce que parce que
nous avons encore une fois des missions
de de de de service public d'où l'idée
du panier minimum pour revenir à ça en
se disant à un moment et par rapport à
ce qui été dit est-ce qu'il est pas
possible et effectivement pour reprendre
l'idée du bureau central de tarification
est-ce qu'il est pas possible de dire
que les assureurs doivent apporter un
panier minimum à partir du moment où on
met en place des missions de de de
service public je rejoins ce que disait
Françoise Gatel sur la question de de de
la mutualisation euh alors évidemment je
représente les intercô France je vais
pas vous dire autrement que
effectivement la logique de
mutualisation à l'échelle des
intercommunalités est intéressante
pourquoi parce que ça permettrait
effectivement de recruter quelqu'un qui
soit
qualifié en matière de en matière
d'assurance parce que c'est extrêmement
technique et ça permettrait
effectivement d'accompagner euh
d'accompagner les communes les plus
petites d'entre elles mais également les
intercommunaités qui gèent des des
équipements souvent plus plus plus
important d'ailleurs je ve juste faire
une petite référence que j'y pense ne
pas oublier dans notre réflexion les
collègues
d'outrem qui de notre qui nous ont fait
remonter les pires difficultés moi je me
souviens d'un d'un d'un collègue maire
disant j'assure je cherche à assurer mon
école par classe c'estàdire qu' découpa
son école pour découper les risques et
pour pour avoir au moins une partie de
l'école assurée là c'est enfin on est
quand même dans des là c'est vrai que on
a passé encore cela oui oui absolument
je je pense que c'est c'est c'est
spécifique
cependant même si on est dans une
logique de de mutualisation même si on
est dans une logique de gestion des
cultures du risque et tout ça tout ça ne
de effectivement il nous faut progresser
là-dessus il nous faut progresser
là-dessus et les intercommunautés
peuvent jouer le jeu cependant il
restera entre nous la question des
événements majeurs ça ça reste quand
même un phénomène parce que on peut dire
on s'organise au mieux mais des
règlements climatiques arrivant on a
parlé du reste cyber les émeutes et
cetera et cetera et et et à un moment on
le voit enfin on peut se le dire
tranquillement honnêtement les assureurs
n'ont pas joué le jeu quoi que combien
de collègues mes l'ont dit en suivant
les émeutes ont découvert que ah ben non
finalement vous êtes pas assuré vous
avez ah bah non finalement vous y êtes
enfin c'est c'est ça nous est remonté
énormément du terrain donc ça aussi
c'est quand
même quelque chose qui doit être
pris pris pris en compte
euh voilà et donc c'est c'est ben je je
pense que je vais en finir je vais je
vais en finir par là en vous remerciant
de votre écoute et effectivement avec la
nécessité d'avancer je rejoins sur la
question vous avez raison d'un
diagnostic très objectif euh le
questionnaire doit doit permettre d'y
répondre et nous contribuerons également
au regard de toutes les remontées qui
nous sont faites du terrain merci à vous
merci beaucoup monsieur Fromentin et je
laisse donc la parole à notre dernier
orateur Alain chrétien merci monsieur le
Président je vais essayer d'être court
et de pas être redondant Françoise Gatel
je pense qu'elle a elle a donné la
définition d'une partie de la réponse
c'est le bon usage du Code des Marchés
public à mon sens tous les outils
existent dans ce code des marchés
publics encore faut-il qu'on les
connaisse et qu'on les utilise bien et
mieux on les connaîtra mieux on les
utilisera moins on aura besoin monsieur
le rapporteur général de moyens
d'ingénierie supplémentaire pour faire
face à une mauvaise utilisation de ce
code des marché public donc avant même
de vouloir proposer des modifications
législatives ou règlementaire au code
des marchés publics commençons déjà avec
le l'État à rédiger un guide des bonnes
pratiques du code des marchés publics
rédigeons un cahier des clauses
administratives générales spécifiques au
code des marchés publics qui nous manque
je pense que ce sont deux outils qui
nous permettrai déjà d'avancer
considérablement sur ce sujet-là sans
complexifier modifier ou Alourd dire le
code des marchés publics c'est mon
sentiment personnel je on le partage
enfin en tout cas on l'évoque avec
jean-ve dagess c'est mon sentiment
personnel avant d'envisager encore des
usines à gaz supplémentaires qui
nécessiteront démter en compéten
supplémentaires en plus de ce qu'on a
pas encore appris avant commençons déjà
par repartir de ce qui existe et comment
on peut optimiser les différentes
procédures qui sont à notre disposition
dans le code des marchés publics et je
dirais que la mutualisation elle viendra
après ne commençons pas à réfléchir à la
mutualisation tant qu'on n pas bien
compris le mode d'emploi de la machine
et puisque mutualisation moi je parle
plutôt de groupement de commande pour
utiliser un terme un peu plus un peu
plus technique et le groupement de
commande ne fonctionne que si vous
n'avez vous avez des risques homogènes
dans le même panier et pour avoir des
risques homogènes il faut connaître ces
risques et que si vous assurez toutes
les écoles du canton mais qu'il y a des
écoles qui sont pourries et d'autres qui
sont toutes neuves et bien votre
assureur ne saura pas répondre et donc
il faut rembobiner depuis le début et
que le guide des bonnes pratiques la
bonne connaissance du bien des biens et
en ensite vous pourrez travailler
ensemble pour faire des propositions
collectives et rééquilibrer le rapport
de force entre l'assureur et l'assurée
le deuxè élément sur le
le notion européenne nous allons
procéder à un parangonage avec les
différents systèmes européens on a déjà
commencer au sein de la la mission c'est
assez complexe parce que les données
sont très parcellaires on a des éléments
de l'OCDE mais pas que et il se trouve
que ça vous étonnera pas notre pays est
un des pays les plus
protecteurs de de l'Union européenne le
fond européen je rappelle que il existe
effectivement un Fond Européen de
soutien mais qui n'est activé que quand
les dégâts c'est la réglementation
l'actuelle dépasse 1,5 % du PIB de la
région concernée donc il y a quand même
déjà une marge et donc l'activation de
ce Fond européen se fait comme on l' on
l'a connu en Allemagne là où les là là
ce qu'on a connu dans le Pas de calis
l'Allemagne c'était 10 fois 100 fois
plus hein c'était c'était donc là leond
le Fond européen était activé est-ce
qu'il faut baisser le seuil est-ce qu'il
faut rentrer dans des négociations avec
Bruxelles sur le sujet vous vous avez 6
sem je pense qu'il faudrait plus de 6
semaines plus de 6 mois voir même plus
de 6 ans pour commencer ce travail là
donc nous en tout cas on nira pas
là-dedans on essaiera de trouver des
données européenne pour essayer de se
comparer par rapport aux collègues mais
de là à modifier le Fond Européen de
soutien je n'en suis pas sûr sur le
problème assurance privée
mutualiste monsieur bet il se trouve que
ce sont les mutualistes qui ne sont pas
censés gagner de l'argent qui ont fait
exploser les primes et que les derniers
assureurs privés qui restent encore dans
les collectivités elles ne l'ont pas
touché donc ça ça c'est un peu
contreintuitif mais le le sujet c'est
que quand les assurances repose sur deux
acteurs le risque est beaucoup plus
fragile et on parlait de chiffres
l'incendie de l'Hôtel de Ville d'Any
c'est 70 millions d'euros de réparation
sur un chiffre d'affaires de 200
millions au niveau national donc vous
avez tout de suite compris que
l'assureur de d'Any je peux vous dire
qu' il l'avait sévère hein 70 millions
sur un chiet d'affairire de 200 millions
chaque année donc notre objectif est
vraiment de faire revenir les
entreprises les assureurs privés et pas
de les ponctionner parce que plus vous
les ponctionnerez moins vous les ferez
revenir je pense que là-dessus au
contraire il faut se montrer sur son
meilleur jour pour les faire revenir et
pas leur taper dessus ni leur faire des
obligations et là c'est sur le panier
minimum quand on parle de panier minimum
ça veut dire qu'on est lgirit le
périmètre de l'assurance obligatoire qui
aujourd'hui est limité à la flotte
automobile et à l'assurance statutaire
là aussi je ne suis pas sûr qu'en
augmentation en augmentant le périmètre
de l'assurance obligatoire on fasse
revenir des assureurs c'est c'est
c'est je je je ne suis pas sûr parce que
le BCT effectivement on a évoqué le BCT
le BCT est très très peu sollicité très
très peu sollicité y compris par le les
les les particuliers et encore moins par
les collectivités locales et lbct il est
chargé de vous retrouver un assureur pas
de vous négocier le prix donc il vous
retrouvera un assureur à 10 ou 20 fois
le tarif que vous aviez avant donc
certes vous aurez un assureur mais le
tarif sera donc le BCT c'est une
solution c'est pas la solution et donc
là-dessus on on on n'aura pas forcément
de de d'ouverture la captive les
captives on n'est pas forcément euh là
aussi si fait pour créer des assurances
spécifiques en tout cas des outils
juridiques on n'est pas sûr en plus que
juridiquement les collectivités
publiques puissent puissent en créer
donc on ne on qui voilà qui se
recapitaliser c'est compliqué nous je
pense pas en tout cas avec la mission
avec jean- y je pense pas qu'on ira
là-dedans euh et puis pour terminer pour
pas être trop long euh sur les
événements majeurs il est clair queà un
moment donné l'état devra assurer ses
responsabilités il est garant de par ses
pouvoirs régaliens de la sécurité
publique quand il n'arrive pas à assumer
ses responsabilités il faut qu'il paye
et à un moment donné c'est c'est et donc
pour terminer euh il faut qu'on
hiérarchise une de vos collègues
sénatrices a évoqué l'auto-assurance et
cetera oui il va falloir faire de
l'auto-assurance pour les petits
sinistres quand on change une fenêtre
parce que vous savez le maire dit bah
tiens la fenêtre là elle est allez je
vais dire à mon assureur tu me la
changes hein on va dire que un gamin a
lancé un ballon de dent comme ça elle
sera changé l'assureur est dit ben
écoute ben oui je vais te la changer ta
fenêtre on va la faire passer en
sinistre hop et c'est un taux de
sinistralité qui augmente ancien temps
avec moi jamais bon euh le rétroviseur
vezou ça le rétroviseur de le
rétroviseur de la Kangou le rétroviseur
de la Kangou municipale on le non on le
déclarera pas on Pera 200 ballle pour
changer le rétroviseur mais on le
déclarera pas donc il y a aussi de
l'auto assurance sur des petits niveaux
au niveau intermédiaire effectivement
faut que les assureurs reviennent sur
l'école a un court- circuit elle a brûlé
donc là on y va et puis le troisième
niveau c'est le niveau sériel le niveau
événementiel
là vous avez quelque chose qui qui qui
qui est bien plus large et là il faut
que l'État prenne ses responsabilités je
ne sais pas quel sera le contenu du
projet de loi qui est proposé par
Gabriel Atal sur réforme de katanat je
pense qu'il s s'inspirera du rapport l'
Gronier mais là aussi il y aura sans
doute des évolutions sur la prise en
charge au niveau catastrophe naturelle
en sachant que c'est pour terminer n
nous leurons pas quel que soi les
mesures que nous préconiserons nous
serons appelés à payer plus cher nos
assurances que ce soit en privé comme en
public en professionnel et cetera parce
que les risques augmentent et que on n
jamais jamais trouvé personne d'autre
que l'assuré pour payer les propres
risques de tout le monde c'est la
solidarité nationale
et l'importance c'est que ces
cotisations augmentent de manière
raisonnable et que aujourd'hui la
surprime de 22 % ne permet pas de
constituer une cagnotte la surprime de
22 % permet juste d'être à l'équilibre
parce que de mémoire on a des risques
climatiques à plus de 2 milliards
d'euros chaque année c'est 5 milliards
d'euros à l'horizon 2030 si on prolonge
les courbes qui sont actuellement
calculé donc de toute façon il faudra
collectivement que nous assumions des
dépenses plus importantes pour couvrir
les risques auquels nous serons
confrontés dans les années qui viennent
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le
Président tu veux rajouter ah ben la
parole est au rapporteur général alors
pardon président juste peut-être
quelques mots je moi je veux je veux
vraiment redire qu'il faut qu'on parte
d'une connaissance la plus aboutie et la
plus objective parce que le débat
actuellement on sent bien il est il est
pas encore passionné mais il pourrait le
devenir puisque il faut qu'on évite de
tomber dans des expressions ou des
positions
accusatrices pu ce qu'on entend C les
ceux qui sont mécontents qui s'estiment
victime injustement enfin et cetera donc
il faut qu'on les entende qu'on relaie
la réalité de la situation sans tomber
dans ce que j'appelle une forme de
démagogie ou parfois de populisme sur
Yaka faucon et cetera parce que je je
souscris je dis ça parce que je me
souviens très bien de la crise sanitaire
ce qu'on a entendu au début sur certains
professionnels les assureurs n'ont qu'à
payer et cetera je suis pas spécialement
je crois que vous chacun a bien compris
dans les rapports qu'on a eu avec les
assureurs je suis pas sûr qui me
considèent comme étant très toujours
compréhensif de l'ensemble de leur
problématique et on doit trouver un
point d'équilibre je rappelle juste que
dans la crise sanitaire ils ont été les
seuls à donner enfin payer un peu plus
d'un milliard on nous avait promis que
d'autres paiaiient c'est le seul donc
quand les assureurs paient c'est les
assurés équipés on va quand même se dire
les choses
tranquillement moi ce Ce à quoi j'aspire
si par ce dossier on peut
remettre comment diraisje de
l'objectivité dans les travaux et les
proposition sur finalement une prise de
responsabilité individuelle et
collective parce que un des avantages du
secteur de l'assurance c'est que
normalement à peu près tout le monde
paye notamment sur ce qui est
obligatoire là c'est pas tout à fait le
cas mais et quand tout le monde pe vous
avez une vraie mutualisation et le
travail doit être fait je partage ce que
disait un chrétien après pour améliorer
la sinistralité bah c'est réduire la
part de risque il y a ce qui dépend de
l'assurée puis y a ce qui dépend pas de
nous si demain avec je dirais la hausse
des températures on a des incendies de
plus comme il y en a au Chili on n pas
encore eu tout à fait ça en France on
commence à le voir en Europe vous
rajoutez je dirais de la difficulté de
la dépense
générale à des risques qui aujourd'hui
de toute façon relèveraient la
responsabilité de l'État voilà mais voà
quand c'est la responsabilité de l'État
on voit aussi ce qu'il en est donc on ne
peut pas faire l'abstraction à la fois
d'être précis sur la multitude des
situations individuelles essayer après
de regarder de quelle manière tout ça
peut rentrer dans quelque chose de plus
organisé systémique avec des étages
voilà je je pense que sur le la
couverture de risque et je crois que ça
peut être un moyen quand même de
réintéresser tous les Français au
sujet parce que si vous regardez par
exemple le sujet des inondation euh
alors on peut dire là où ça a été
construit récemment c'est une faillite
collective mais vous avez quand même des
zones qui étaient inondabl
historiquement où il y avait des petites
inondations régulières mais maintenant
les phénomènes sont beaucoup plus
intenses concentré dans le temps et
c'est beaucoup plus violent et et ça
fait pourtant 250 ans que les bâtiment
sont là donc il faut il faut éviter de
rejeter aussi la faute
sur l'autre voilà donc il faut notre
objectif ça va être de de regarder aussi
comment on peut voilà améliorer les
choses tout en étant concret et en
répondant au sujet qui est euh le marché
comment il s'ajuste il s'adapte et il
répond mieux voilà pardon Monsieur Merci
monsieur le rapporteur
général non mais tu tu as raison moi ti
d'exemple dans mon département pour la
première fois il y a 2 ans on a eu des
feux extrêmement conséquents chez
Philippe Chalopin notamment notre ami
maire de beuger que beaucoup beaucoup
connaissent et ça c'est tout à fait
nouveau ce
risque nord de ces type de ces types de
de risque n'existait pas et d'autres
exemples en Méloir les certaines Franch
pour bris de vitre sont passé de 500 € à
500000 ce qui fait
des des augmentations
totalement 10000 100ou bien
sûr voilà en tous les cas merci beaucoup
merci à nos intervenants je crois que
c'était un échange passionnant et puis
on attend je crois que nos collectivités
attendent des réponses des pistes merci
beaucoup merci à tous et bonne
journée